das wird die Emoats einstellen
Leute UPS hat es voll verkackt heute
Hallo Captain CK, bist ja richtig früh da
Ich kann doch mal meine VM anschmeißen
Ja UPS hat es heute voll verkackt
und zwar ich hatte mir ja also eigentlich wollte ich ja am Wochenende jetzt die ganzen
Geschichten schon gestern ankommen sollen eigentlich wollte ich am Wochenende ein
bisschen Bustler Stream wieder machen weil ich habe mir jetzt extra eine Kamera so ein
Stativ bestellt was man an den Tisch machen kann und eine ordentliche Beleuchtung und heute
also ich habe mir so ein Ding bestellt wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich viel zu teuer für das was
es kann keine Ahnung wenn ich keylight ring ring ring light ring light das da eigentlich
viel zu teuer ist schön hell so und zumindest das wurde mit UPS verschickt so und das Problem
an UPS ist UPS hat auf der einen Seite Verzögerung und auf der anderen Seite liefert UPS nicht
Samstag das ist natürlich eine ziemliche Kackkombination vielleicht hat sich das auch
geändert weiß nicht oh UPS ist auch am Samstag für sie tätig ah exzellent also früher
hat UPS nie am Samstag geliefert genau ach so das ist wenn man das ist wenn man ein bisschen
auf preis bezahlt also früher hat UPS definitiv kein Samstag Zustellung gemacht das weiß
ich weil ich habe mal vor ein paar Jahren hatte ich was bestellt ich glaube es war sogar
bei alternate und das war UPS und ich habe es express bestellt und es kam nicht und kam
nicht und es hätte theoretisch Samstag kommen sollen und Samstag kam dann nix nicht fail
ich downloade schon mal all clocks HD hier 14 14 Monate hier guckst du mal an hier das
ist ja schon richtig so viele subscriptions exzellent übrigens die Chancen dass es bald
neue Emotes gibt sind gestiegen
was hältst du von dem Gerät ideal networks Leistungs Messgerät Navitec NT Pro ich habe
keine Ahnung was man link ich suche mal danach nach was ich kann aber wahrscheinlich nichts
dazu sagen aber der Name ist schon mal ist schon mal also in dem Namen müsste noch ein
bisschen mehr Killer Killer Fertility Headshot Pro Hercules Windschild 3D Ultra sein ehrlich
gesagt ich habe keine Ahnung was das ist also ja der Netzwerk Tester aber ich habe damit
keinerlei Erfahrung wahrscheinlich ist es teuer easy easy das kostet es ist ja ein Schnapper
kann man sich mal gönnen
skillkiller hast du nicht vorhin was geschrieben im Discord warum deine Festplatte mit dem
Raid so voll ist oder war das jemand anderes mit ähnlichem Name
ja teureres gibt es immer aber ich finde Netzwerk Tester für 1500 Euro ist schon ganz
ordentlich
ein leute soll ich mache mal download an also cinnamon kann man nicht probieren cinnamon
sagt in der vm aber richtig deswegen probieren wir mal xfce und mate aus
hier bei the way ich lade natürlich selbstverständlich über torrent nur linux isos runter sollte
sollte gleich das hast du dir gestern gegönnt hast du das billiger bekommen oder hast du
einfach mal 1000 euro übrig mein kann ja sein ist ja nichts verwerfliches dran aber
selbst wenn ich einfach so 1000 euro übrig hätte ich würde es mir nicht kaufen
cinnamon sagt auch sonst ich habe es ewig nicht ausprobiert
ach docker volumes ah verstehe ich hatte drauf getippt also skillkiller ich hatte drauf getippt
dass du dass deine einhaut voll laufen weil du viele kleine dateien hast so download mir
ja evo weiß habe ich noch nie gehört excellent mama evo weiß und und mate alles klar das
ist doch das ist doch mal sehr schön wenn man mal hier mit 25 mb die sekunde saugt das
hat aber was da funktioniert dann hat sich endlich dass ich wenigstens gelohnt bei unity
media sich was schnelleres zu holen da habe ich euch eigentlich schon jemals erzählen
dass mich dass mich wurde von doppelt gebetet hat mit dem umstellen vom vom tarif ich hatte
ja unity media und in dieser übergangsphase von unity media wurde von da haben die dann
irgendwann also die machen ja diese was was kommt eigentlich raus wenn man nach june
zu unity media punkte geht jetzt und aber wurde von raus also ich hatte ich hatte ja lange
Zeit einen 100 mbit anschluss bei unity media und die telekom hat sie auch nicht geschafft
bei mir irgendwie auch eine ansatzweise was vergleichbares bei mir zu schaffen ja so
und unity media hat big brain taktik gemacht hallo ist musik bis sie laut unity media hat
absolut massive brain tactics gemacht die haben einfach jedes jahr den bestehenden tarif
um irgendwie eins zwei euro angehoben und die haben mir dann parallel geschickt immer
noch ein brief ja herr max hier gibt es das so viel billiger bei uns und nach ein paar
jahren wo ich das ignoriert habe habe ich halt irgendwann dann keine ahnung fünf euro
insgesamt schon mehr bezahlt im monat für nichts mehr mehr leistung ja wollen sie baro
guck mal guck mal guck mal hier wo blortz punkt tv ah jetzt geht's schnell ok komisch
was gemacht also ich habe probiert von meinem anderen rechner aufzurufen also von nicht
vom anderen rechner form von meinem anderen account und da war überhaupt kein problem
komisch naja vielleicht war es auch nur der firefox zumindest um die sache mal ab abzuschließen
und dann haben sie dann habe ich gesagt ja gut macht halt stellt um aber es ist wichtig
dass ich meinen ipv4 behalte oder eben und ordentlichen richtig echten dual stack bekomme
so also alles klar support hat mir das ganze bestätigt ja bekommen sie alles klar hier
ipv4 wunderbar es ändert sich nix bei der umstellung dann habe ich power upload dazu
gebucht dass ich 40 400 mb down kriegen und 40 mbit ab oder irgendwie so glaube ich war
das alles alles gut umgestellt umgestellt ging alles verhältnismäßig gut und so nach
einer woche war ging ging gar nichts mehr richtig da habe ich mal in mein unity media modem
reingeguckt habe festgestellt ich bin du ich bin wieder bei dual stack light am start einfach
eine woche eine woche quasi später dann umgestellt dass ich nicht meckere oder vielleicht noch
davon zurück drehte oder irgendwas naja zumindest dann habe ich den support angeschrieben
wie kann das denn sein wie kann das sein dass ich hier von euch die zusicherung habt da
ändert sich nix und jetzt eine woche später wurde es geändert haben die gedacht he doesn't
know he lacks critical information und haben gesagt das müssen sie machen was was er total
bescheuert ausreden ist warum warum sie mir das vorher anders bestätigt haben sind nicht
darauf eingegangen und dann haben sie gesagt ja aber ich könnte ja power upload buchen
dann bekomme ich richtig echt dual stack moment ich habe doch schon power upload sonst hätte
ich ja keine 40 mbit upload normal sind es nur 20 ja ich soll einfach noch mal power
upload buchen und jetzt bezahle ich zweimal power upload bekomme nur einmal power upload
und dual stack light und und und richtig echten dual stack also jetzt habe ich richtig echten
dual stack aber richtig gebaited es sind bleibt irgendwie nur 2 euro oder so aber richtig
hart gebaited und wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich kassieren die noch übelst
professionen für nach dem motto habe ich abgezockt ja also na shitstorm auf twitter
ganz ehrlich die 2 euro war mir jetzt egal shitstorm auf twitter gab es nur wo der stream
die ganze zeit abgekackt ist und was da auch witzig war nachdem ich what the fuck nachdem
ich irgendwie 5 6 mal geschrieben habe auf twitter und wurde davon mich über wurde
davon ausgekotzt habe irgendwann hat er dann so ein so ein so ein ich weiß nicht was es
ist so ein community manager typ zurückgeschrieben das war eindeutig kein normaler normaler
support mensch der zurückgeschoben hat zurückgeschrieben hat und und meinte auch so was in der richtung
wie ja wenn ich mich bei ihnen melde dann kriege ich auch eine gutschrift für die ausgefallenen
zeiten und so da hat so voll auf gut wetter gemacht habe ich mit aha aha deswegen geht
es jetzt anscheinend weil da muss ich immer erst die richtigen positionen einschalten
dass der kram funktioniert was natürlich auch im umkehrschluss heißt wenn du keine
20 25 k leute leute auf twitter hast du den kram lesen dann hast du bist du verloren was
eigentlich auch unfair ist was heißt du hast deckbar wurde davon und du hast deck bedeutet
dass du übrigens eine gute frage die kommt nämlich öfters muss man mit chat anmachen
also dual stack bedeutet also richtig also echter dual stack bedeutet du kommst bekommst
eine ipv4 adresse eine richtig echte publik ipv4 adresse und eine ipv6 adresse bei ipv6
adresse muss man nicht public sagen weil da gibt es genug so und mit richtig echtem
dual stack also was ja eigentlich der normale dual stack ist hast du beides du bekommst
eine ipv4 und eine ipv6 die du beide vollwertig nutzen kannst viel interessanter ist es was
ist dual stack lite mal gucken ob es da ein schönes bild zugibt bevor ich da lange rum
labere also dual stack lite ist nur ein teil des problemes das eigentliche problem ist
dual stack lite mit nut auf anbieter seite geht ja nicht viel anders aber mal gucken
ob es ein schönes bild für gibt wo ich mir das jetzt aus den fingern saugen muss der
after da ist er der after das heißt bei unity media auch wirklich so also dual stack lite
ist die auch static nee bei unity media und beziehungsweise bei vodafone sind die sachen
so halbstatic die ändern sich alle paar monate mal aber static sind die ips nicht nee also
nicht die ipv4 die ipv6 ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung die könnte ohne probleme static sein
so und dual stack lite das ist viel interessanter was dual stack lite ist und deswegen auch
mal zu erklären warum das so extrem sackt hier gibt es keine gescheiten bilder aber
ich versuche das mal ich versuche das mal an dieser geschichte hier zu erklären also
also bei dual stack lite geht das folgendermaßen ihr bekommt eine ipv6 adresse sonst nichts
also normale adressen ihr bekommt eine private ipv4 adresse aus dem aus dem unity media pool
oder sonst was mit der ihr nicht direkt erreichbar seid und wenn ihr ins internet wollt über
ipv4 dann passiert bei dual stack lite folgendes euer traffic wird eingepackt über ipv6 getunnelt
zu unity media bei unity media wieder ausgepackt und dort teilt ihr euch einen ausgangspunkt
mit mehreren kunden die die gleiche absender ip verwenden so und das ist der sogenannte
after der ausgangspunkt das ding heißt wirklich so also ihr kommt von euch über ip kommt hier
über ipv6 rein zum internet provider dort wird das ganze wieder ausgepackt euer ipv4
package wird wieder ausgepackt dann geht ihr über so einen komischen after gateway bester
name michael 50 billionen auch mal wieder am start nice lang nicht gesehen und dann
teilt ihr euch mit ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht wie viel sind ich sag jetzt einfach
50 kunden oder so oder wahrscheinlich sind viel mehr so eine public ipv4 adresse um ins
internet zu gehen problem dabei ist dass sobald ihr damit zum beispiel so was wie port weiter
leitung machen wollt weil ihr einen minecraft server hosten wollt oder weil ihr vielleicht
per vpn von der arbeit rein müsst oder von mobile oder sonst wie dann geht es nicht es
funktioniert nicht weil ihr könnt keine port weiter leitung auf dem router von eurem provider
machen es sei denn unity media gibt euch die zugangsdaten und ihr seid in der lage das zu
konfigurieren aber ja überraschung ist wahrscheinlich sind die meisten nicht der lager zu konfigurieren
und zweitens gibt euch unity media garantiert auch nicht die zugangsdaten so deswegen hat man
gelitten das heißt die einzig realistische variante dann ist entweder einen eigenen tunnel
machen geht auch eine möglichkeit oder solange nerven bis man dual stack bekommt eigene tunnel
ist auch kein also ein eigener tunnel ist jetzt kein hexenwerk man kann sich einen ganz billigen
server mieten und das da drüber machen also das ist jetzt nicht so dass das ding übrigens
eins und eins die die hier die wo ich mir diesen ein euro im monat server bestellt habe die
haben ich gebadet die haben ich gebadet ich wollte ja ich wollte den server ausprobieren
einfach so auf spaß an der freude weil ich mir gedacht habe wie gut kann ein 1 euro server
sein ist diese geteilte ip adresse nicht auch ein problem bei ip bans doch deswegen muss
man total oft google captures und so gedürnt eingeben also ich habe mir das diese geschichte
gekauft hierbei genau ein hier den da den habe ich mir gekauft übrigens übrigens wenn
ihr wenn ihr das kauft was auch witzig ist wenn ihr sagt ich will mir das kaufen ob und
u 20 ja jetzt darf nicht rum weiter und ihr sagt dann ach ich will ich will das nur mal
einen monat ausprobieren da kostet 11 euro also ihr habt ihr habt die auswahl 12 euro
für ein jahr oder 11 euro für einen monat excellent klingt klingt gut zumindest haben
die mir eine rechnung geschickt also die nach mega g bait außer ich habe eine rechnung von
den bekommen da stand drin ich bezahlen ein euro für den server und 499 für die public
ip allerdings haben sie public ip nicht abgerechnet ich verstehe den sinn nicht davon warum es
aufgeführt ist für 499 also ich dachte erstens also als erstes wo ich das gesehen habe habe
ich mir gedacht ihr habt mich übelst verarscht ich bezahle quasi 6 euro im monat statt 1
ne mache ich nicht ich bezahle tatsächlich nur ein euro aber es steht auf der rechnung
public ip 499 ich habe keine ahnung was die da für rechnungen schreiben
die smart home heizung das verstehe ich nicht also es ist auch nur ein euro was mir abgerechnet
wurde aber mal angerufen nein warum es ist danach es ist doch unterm strich ein euro nur
das passt ja also das was sie abrechnen ist ok falls man das jetzt nicht verstanden hat
also das ist in ordnung aber auf der rechnung stand 499 public ip und schaut hä warum das
denn habe ich nicht kapiert naja ich muss mal kurz hier vermute ich nicht den baro wobei
habe ich das eigentlich schon mal im stream erzählt ich hatte mal auf der arbeit übelst
peinliches meeting allerdings war das remote da ging es um irgendwelche prozesse und dokumentar
tionsgeschichten und sonst was also das meeting an sich war übelst übelst langweilig aber
das meeting wurde von einer gehalten die ihr privates notebook verwendet hat macbook macbook
macbook wohlgemerkt ja also richtig richtige prozess struktur stonks meeting und das problem
war dass sie die ganze zeit hier oben so einen ordner hatte und wisst ihr wie der ordner
hieß also ihr müsst euch vorstellen die hat dann quasi irgendwelche dokumentationsseiten
aufgemacht so nach dem motor ok jetzt gucken wir uns die prozessübersicht für xy an jetzt
gucken wir uns die prozessübersicht für sonst was an und ich hatte da oben den ordner der
hieß dicksteady das war schon postchamp ordner und der ordner der war quasi da wo du auch
in die nähe kommst wenn du deine bookmarks aufmachst wie hieß der ordner dicksteady also
quasi jepp ich mein vielleicht ist es nun unglückliche ordnerbezeichnung kann ja sein
dass es nun unglückliche ordnerbezeichnung ist aber daddy daddy hieß das nix daddy komisch
bei mir stand es mit 499 drauf aber es wurde nicht abgerechnet ja und die hat halt die
ganze das ganze miet das ganze miet gelangen ist die halt immer mit der maus in die nähe
dieses ordner ausgekommen und immer so mal ein bookmark aufmachen ja die leiche hat mir
da ein surfergold für ein euro weil ich ausprobieren wollte ob das was taug ich erstelle mal nebenbei
schon die vm ups was haben wir hier alles auf erstmal alles weg alles weg machen leute
übrigens soll ich euch mal die neueste version von von der kamera überwachungs software zeigen
bevor wir anfangen mit der vm ich kann ich machen weil ich habe ich habe vorhin wieder
was gepusht habe vorhin wieder was gepusht def keck weh ich glaube das muss ich überschreiben
geht remote update origin guck mal origin def monka es da ist richtig geht reset minus
minus hart origin def bäm zack alles klar passt ich zeig's euch mal also ok das gartenaufnahme
video machen wir wieder weg das kameratool ist die neue smart heizung ne bei dem kameratool
tut sich was bei der smart heizung tut sich ja nichts also ich starte das jetzt mal schnell
ich hoffe das funktioniert so ne das kann so so funktioniert das schon mal gar nicht
habe ich habe ich denn überhaupt irgendwas laufen hier an kameras hier ist er schon hier
ist er schon hier ist er schon wieder abkacken jetzt muss ich erstmal sagen jan was sagt
man da bild install so ich muss jetzt erstmal alle javascript dependencies installieren docker
ist gestartet ffmpeg ist auch gestartet aber ich muss erstmal alle javascript dependencies
installieren weil javascript dependencies möchten gerne das halbe internet nachladen das ist
halt nun mal so und jetzt kann ich das starten jetzt schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert
es könnte sein das es nicht tut aber schauen wir mal so starten lets go champ was ist hier
los oh ich bin ein kackknub wa äh ja moment das lässt sich einfach fixen ich bin nütz
zu blöd das machen wir sogar im vim jetzt weil man nichts großartiges machen muss database
ja ja ich habe ja meine datenbank nicht mit eingecheckt ist ja ganz klar dass es nicht
funktioniert so jetzt aber ok also sollte alles gestartet sein guck mal mal wusste gar nicht
dass es einen menschen gibt der vim bedient klar vim ist für die richtigen hacker mans
ok also machen wir mal auf hier ich mach mal neu ich mach mal hier jetzt experience wie
wenn ihr es daheim macht also jetzt gehen wir mal auf localhost da weiß ich wo ist port
5000 da läuft das ganze so es ist keine kamera geedit keine kamera ok gibt doch keine fehler
schau mal schau mal gut also sprich wenn ihr das zum ersten mal startet dann kommt dieser
dieser screen wir fügen jetzt mal zwei kameras zwei kameras hinzu also so enden wir mal die
erste kamera das ding heißt testkamera und jetzt brauchen wir ein rtsp stream äh was
ist jemand für rtsp stream ich hab noch eine history nennen wir den das ist auch ein rtsp
test stream und dann lokale rtsp test stream aber nehmen wir erstmal den das ist dem war
übertreibens wieder so ok hier unten kann man noch eingeben falls die kamera username
und password braucht inklusive guck mal hier wie nice das ist wenn ich den password eingebe
dann ist der sternchen wenn ich da drauf klicke bamm sieht man das password ist nicht nice
gemacht so also kamera speichern so jetzt sieht man ne vorschau jetzt kann man object detection
anmachen ich glaube detection für leute kann man anmachen ich glaube das ist nicht allzu
sinnvoll wenn man jetzt diesen vogel object detectet deswegen lasst oh ich hab noch ein
bug drinne ich hab die dinger nicht ausgeblendet ich hab die icons nicht ausgeblendet ok ok
machen wir gleich so skippen wir das ein timer brauchen wir auch nicht also wunderbar aber
die erste kamera geedet jetzt enden wir nochmal ne lokale kamera rtsp wieder das ist lokal
das ist ne schleife von ner kameraaufnahme bei mir setup enden wir die nächste kamera
hier ist jetzt test 2 so und jetzt zeige ich euch auch nochmal was nicees was mittlerweile
funktioniert schaut mal sobald also hier ist nur eine kamera drin jetzt sobald ich die zweite
kamera adde passt mal auf sobald ich die zweite kamera adde bamm automatisch erkenne dass
die zweite kamera drin ist ohne dass ich was machen muss also sprich auf allen endgeräten
die buttons könnt ihr mal ignorieren die sollten eigentlich gar nicht da sein so ne
eine sache die ich auch noch gemacht hab ich hab hilfetexte hier oben gemacht wenn die
leute keine ahnung haben was sache ist dann kann man sich hilfetexte einblenden lassen
so jetzt machen wir mal die erkennung an für die für die leute mach mal schnell so guck
jetzt erkennt er die person im bild das kennt er ja schon na das ist jetzt nix neues was
jetzt neu ist das ist richtig stylisch ausfaded habt ihr das gesehen habt ihr das gesehen
wie es ausfaded ha poggers fade action ist das hier so man kann jetzt in die advanced
konfig gehen man kann einstellen ob man aufnehmen will oder nur erkennen will weil es könnte
ja zum beispiel sein dass jemand sagt hey ich will nicht jedes mal die aufnahme starten
ich will bloß benachrichtigt werden wenn leute durch die kamera laufen wäre ja auch
sinnvoll ne einfach der ausfaden oder wie auch immer die jugend heute sagt die jugend
würde sagen ich fühle ich fühle das ausfaden ich fühle das voll oder irgendwie sowas habt
ihr auch gesehen es fadet auch ein es fadet auch ein aber einfaden tut schneller als ausfaden
ja man kann das übrigens ich ich zeig ich ich wir warten jetzt mal bis hier wieder
person durchs bild läuft da kann ich euch nämlich zeigen dass das tatsächlich dynamisch
funktioniert je nachdem wann du den knopf drückst und wann nicht dauert noch 10 sekunden
oder so dann läufts wieder durchs bild ist das deine kamera ja denn das ist ein ausschnitt
von der kamera an meinem haus das ist immer der gleiche das ist immer der gleiche loop
von der kamera so guck jetzt mache ich aus jetzt mache ich aus und jetzt erkennt er
nix mehr also sprich dass also dass es updated sich live wenn man das hier anklickt was
natürlich auch merkwürdig ist dass der neu lädt wenn ich motion detection aktiviere
und wenn nicht das ist nicht sinn und zweck der sache das kann man aber noch optimieren
so also jetzt haben wir die kamera hinzugefügt wunderbar zack jetzt kann man noch timer einstellen
sprich ob man keine ahnung jede nacht um 2 uhr aufnehmen will oder nicht so jetzt fügen
wir noch eine dritte kamera hinzu ein knopf für setup fehlt noch test 3 zack machen wir
das gleiche noch mal so das lassen wir jetzt so zack skip finish so ihr seht jetzt haben
wir einen davon zu jetzt haben wir 3 kameras drin einmal testvideo und zweimal also einmal
online testvideo und einmal testvideo lokal bei mir ich mache mal ein bisschen kleiner
dass man sieht das hier dürfte ungefähr so die größe sein die man auch bei einem hier
ist ein bisschen fett ne übrigens ich hab ich hab die buttons gehen werden so der der
ist verbackt die buttons werden auch dynamisch größer guckt euch das mal an ja so also ähm
normalerweise sieht das übrigens so aus ohne buttons hier oben sieht man das motion detection
alles aber nur bei der kamera wenn ich meine kamera ins internet schrieme kannst du das
auch einbinden ja ja kann ich so lange du nicht die salami vor der kamera gleich machst
kann ich das machen so und jetzt jetzt zeige ich euch mal was ich ganz neu gemacht habe
heute aber dazu muss man was aufnehmen ich nehme mal kurz was auf es ist egal wo wir
was aufnehmen hier oder hier also ich nehme mal kurz was auf so nehmen wir mal 10 sekunden
was auf die motion erkennung bei einem ja ja ja die erkennt dann sicherlich die eine
andere person zwischendurch so wir nehmen gerade mal was auf zum testen zack so mal mal
aufnahme aus aus haben wir noch mal eine zweite aufnahme an lassen die auch noch mal kurz
laufen also man kann aufnahmen kannst du auf drei arten triggern von der kamera entweder
nach einem timer von hand oder durch die wenn eine person durchs bild läuft so jetzt muss
ich mal eine sache noch machen weil das ist noch verpackt ich muss die aufnahme manuell
moveen weil es doch nicht im richtigen richtigen verzeichnis aufnimmt aber kann ich alles haben
so und jetzt passt mal auf was ich was ich heute gemacht habe ist wenn ich mir jetzt
die aufnahmen angucken will gibt es nämlich einen zweiten knopf ich weiß nicht ob ich
ja schon aufgefallen ist und jetzt siehst du die aufnahmen die man gemacht hat mit der
kamera man sieht jetzt zum beispiel wir haben hier eine manuelle aufnahme übrigens ist
noch die bug ausgabe da unten ja da schreibe ich an startzeit endzeit und sowas rein und
jetzt kannst du auch sagen ok zack abspielen jetzt kannst du die aufnahme angucken ganz
klar vorspulen sowas und und jetzt passt mal auf wenn ich das wenn ich was anderes
abspiele dann geht sogar der pause button von hier weg dahin und jetzt ist richtig big
brain wenn ich jetzt pause drücke dann gibt es sogar ein anderes icon dass ich weiß dass
ich jetzt die gleiche sache abspiele und pause wieder starte ich würde euch übrigens auch
zeigen dass man hier scrollen kann ich nehme mal übrigens auch noch mal oh mist das updated
sich nämlich auch live was habe ich für kameras ich habe china china camps so ich zeige euch
was das update sich ups das update sich nämlich auch live irgendwie habe ich jetzt kaputt
gemacht was auch immer oder update sich doch nicht live oh das update sich doch nicht live
das habe ich sollte sich eigentlich live updaten sobald die sobald die kamera aufnahme fertig
ist sind die personen kästen dann auch im video nö ok das mit dem updaten funktioniert
nicht automatisch sollte aber eigentlich schimpft in den back weiß nicht aber zumindest
man sieht dass es funktioniert wenn ich hier jetzt wieder aufmacht dann sind die kameras
alles die aufnahmen alle drinnen ich nehme noch mal kurz ein bisschen mehr auf dass ich
einmal spulen nicht spulen scrollen kann dass man sieht dass das scrollen auch funktioniert
ne ne das moving ist nur dass es abspielen kann die dateien moving muss ich nur dass
es abspielen kann in der datenbank drin stehen die dinge auch so ich mache noch mal kurz
drei aufnahmen dass ich ein bisschen ein bisschen scrollen kann übrigens passt mal auf ich
zeige euch mal noch noch ein geiles feature was jetzt noch gar nicht zur sprache gekommen
ist zu den fragen im chat zeige ich gleich was guck mal ich nehme jetzt nur mal kurz
auf 1 2 3 4 ich habe jetzt nur 2 3 sekunden aufgenommen und jetzt schauen wir uns mal
die letzte aufnahme an also die da und euch wird auffallen dass diese aufnahme ja der
fängt die fängt nicht mit dem keyframe an guck mal die aufnahme ich habe drei sekunden
aufgenommen und die aufnahme ist 13 sekunden lang woher kommt das das kommt daher dass
ich immer 10 sekunden aufnehme so ein bisschen wie bei shadowplay die ich rückwirkend bei
einer aufnahme dran klatsche das heißt wenn jetzt die erkennung auslöst das eine durchs
bild läuft dann habe ich die rückwirkenden 10 sekunden noch wo ihr ins bild reingelaufen
ist also sprich ich verpasst nichts also wenn der postbote kommt und es löst aus dann habe
ich sogar noch drauf wie der postbote aus dem auto steigt was natürlich nice ist so
jetzt move ich das ganze mal so den freshen wir mal der brau immer ein bisschen keyframe
drinne ist muss ich auch noch mal ändern so guckt mir sie was das was macht das da warum
scrollt das da durch z index ja auf jeden fall sowas in der richtung ha ja gut das
machen wir nicht jetzt aber nur dass es mal gesehen habt na so genau das jetzt neu habe
ich heute eingebaut man kann es natürlich auch zumachen und wieder aufmachen und für
andere kamera ups für andere kamera starten ja was jetzt eigentlich nur noch fehlt ist
noch ein button dass ich die kamera nachträglich editieren kann also sprich dass ich settings
ändern kann nachträglich ein paar kleinigkeiten also im großen und ganzen habe ich jetzt fast
alles drin was drin sein soll das sind spinnenweben an der kamera so also kommen wir zu den questions
die drin sind bevor wir mit uns linux mint angucken welches framework ist das das hier
also es gibt zwei sachen es gibt das backend das ist dort net core also sprich asp.net
core als für web anwendung gibt ja gibt ja nix nix anderes für web anwendung was dort
net angeht das hat ja microsoft alles sich einverleibt also das backend ist asp.net core
und das hier ist vue js im frontend übrigens wisst ihr wisst ihr was auch nice ist dass
der das guck mal die buttons die buttons gelten seht ihr das warte mal ich muss die mausknopf
loslassen guck mal die buttons gelten je nach je nach größe gelten die buttons so und ich
habe auch darauf geachtet dass es immer alles sichtbar ist so ja da werde ich die tage ein
bisschen weiter dran machen ich hoffe da kommt irgendwas benutzbares raus bis mein urlaub
fertig ist können wir das alle mal ausprobieren ok ich mache mal aus ich scoll mal kurz durch
ob es ein paar andere sachen gab im chat ja genau haben schon angerufen also wie gesagt
die personen in kästen sind nicht im video das ist rein frontend wo das drüber gemalt
wird ist auch besser so weil ich mein im video will man ja keine kästen drin haben warum
kannst du sowas alles das liegt daran weil ich so viele prime subs bekommen hab und ihr
wisst ja mit jedem prime sub steigt der durchschnitts iq im chat ja wie gesagt könnte man probieren
ja richtig also 1 2 3 4 also ich hab nur ich hab bis 9 aber icons hab ich nur für 1 2
3 weil hier hab ich immer einen browser auf hier hab ich den terminal auf in der regel
und hier hab ich irgendwie anderes gedöns noch auf meistens hab ich hier irgendwie sowas
da noch auf oder studio code oder irgendwas in der richtung und das ist i3 also magiaro
und i3 als window manager ist ja kein desktop in dem sinn genau aber i3 ist jetzt nichts
was ich noobs empfehlen würde i3 ist halt ziemlich tastaturzentriert und shortcuts
fokussiert also für windows umsteiger direkt ist das nix
auf der arbeit regt mich dieses javascript zeug so hart auf das bauen von einem container
mit ui und backend dauert 10 min ja deswegen macht man das auch nicht ja doch die ganzen
bilddinger sind ja mittlerweile mit webinterface mit jenkins hat es angefangen damals kennt
noch einer jenkins bevor er jenkins hieß der hieß ja mal hudson ursprünglich das
war eine crap software mittlerweile rede eigentlich nein nicht nicht der world of warcraft jenkins
weißt du ob ich vor allem von vor allem zu hyper wie konvertieren kann habe ich schon
nie gemacht geht aber ziemlich sicher ok alles klar weißt du ob sich das lohnt turtle
beach tactical controller erst mal checken ist es ein reflink nein ok alles klar ne glaube
nicht also wenn ich sowas wie boost und noise background noise limiter lese ne ich glaub
das ist nicht so sinnvoll dann hol dir lieber irgendwie den halbwegs gescheiten mixer kannst
du auch mehr quellen dran anschließen problematisch halt mit manchen jetzt also ich glaube nicht
dass sich das lohnt ehrlich gesagt diese dinger sind meistens eher pains champ als
dass es was bringt wenn ein mikrofon rauscht ist die beste variante ein besseres mikrofon
beziehungsweise nicht die on board soundkarte ja das stimmt auch twitch prime sub dankeschön
für den sub massive subscription dankeschön vier monate schon so ich leg mal mein linux
mint vm an weil eigentlich wollten wir das ja heute machen den lassen wir mal an hier
weiß man ob man das brauche also neu vm ups war fort neu vm custom ich habe immer noch
15 obwohl ich bin in sechst habe ich euch erzählt dass ich mir einen fein war workstation
16 16 key bestellt habe bei software kong klingt äußerst vertrauenswerken software
kong wer hat von euch jemand schon zufällig bei software kong was bestellt ok also next
wir installieren später selbst linux jawoll gibt es da eigentlich mittlerweile ne gibt
es nicht oder aber wir können ubuntu nehmen weil mint ist ja immer noch ubuntu based so
wir machen es nicht auf c wir machen es auf jeden fall auf min torz alter windows manchmal
habe ich den manchmal habe ich das gefühl windows will mich zubaden das ist ein bug
leute das ist ein windows bug ich glaube wir haben gerade ein windows bug gefunden ne jetzt
hat es funktioniert aber ich glaube das war ein windows bug gerade wenn man zum ersten
mal den file explorer irgendwie aufmacht und ein ordner anlegt und nicht rausklickt und
direkt ok dann backt's rum ich möchte dass der spiel sound von der xbox auf meinen kopfhörer
geht die hauptsächlich an meinem pc angeschlossen sind
dann hol doch sowas hier das ist sogar wahrscheinlich sogar eine ganze ecke billiger
irgendwie sowas da in der richtung falls die überhaupt noch gibt die gibt es gar nicht
mehr ok ja gut wenn es hier nicht mehr gibt dann weiß ich auch nicht jetzt ja alle mal
besser als dieses komische gamer ding ja go xlr den habe ich mir letzten sogar angeguckt
der ist cool der ist aber eine ganze ecke teurer das kann ich da doch viel 500 euro
oder so gekostet endlich hast du den stream wieder gefunden excellent so guck mal mint
next also wieviel cpu cores bekommt er 3 ne ne eine cpu 3 cores ah 4 kommen sind großzügig
das kann ein bisschen flutschen 4 gigabyte ram sollte reichen ja nut darfst du benutzen
ach gut alles exquisite 20g na 20g ist ein bisschen wenig 40g single file mint so also
erst mal den drucke entfernen ich weiß ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung warum die
immer noch ein drucke standard milchen zu fügen und sound machen wir vielleicht auch
raus weil sound backt öfters warum machen wir einfach mal so also und nun cd einlegen
und mal gucken mit was fange man an mit mate oder mit xfce anfangen ich mache das in single
file weil ich schon rumgebacken hatte mit windows dass das die vm eingefroren hat zwischendurch
weil er irgendwelche datei nicht lesen konnte also seitdem mache ich immer single file
mate von mal anfangen ich muss das doch gar nicht zweimal installieren oder ich kann auch
mit sicher ich kann auch mit sicherheit einfach weil cinnamon in vms kacke funktioniert ich
kann auch mit sicherheit einfach wenn ich jetzt in mate installieren in xfce nachinstallieren
oder da muss ich das ja nicht neu installieren ok start mal gucken ob wir vm ob sie es mittlerweile
geschafft haben vm tools dabei zu haben
ich verstehe kein wort ich installiere gerade linux in der vm um mal zu gucken ob die neuen
mintversion immer noch was taugen weil mint ist immer das was ich nupes empfehle so nach
dem motto hier welches linux soll ich von das gerade ok sind keine vm tools installiert
schon mal kann man kann man die einfach so nachinstallieren noch mal oh nee install open
open vm nee wie war das wie hießen die dinger open vm tools ahja hier desktop excellent
kokona tastatur das hintergrundbild hat sie nicht ganz
überlebt aber es funktioniert schon mal install vor allem gleich virtuelle maschine ja vm
vm ich habe gesagt eine vm also hat sie ähnlich angehört ja ok man verschiebt hier fenster
mit alt das irritiert mich schon mal ok also installieren auf englisch gut aber tastatur
layout nehmen wir german what what german no dead keys next install multimedia mach
mal mach mal schad nix ich frag mich immer wenn ich mint sehe mint ist ja auch nur ein
aufsatz auf ubuntu mit ein bisschen custom zeug also wahrscheinlich mittlerweile relativ
viel custom zeug ich will das jetzt nicht schlecht machen also da frage ich mich doch
warum ist das offizielle ubuntu desktop so verschissen mittlerweile das war mal ursprünglich
die distro die jeder noob verwendet hat aber mittlerweile ist das ja unbenutzbar geworden
nee 20 stunden ist richtig eklig ich hab das letztes mal wieder angeguckt du kannst immer
noch kein track und drop auf dem desktop machen und sowas ubuntu desktop ist total abartig
irgendwie da wird da benutze ich ja fast lieber windows also also ich werde damit nicht warm
ich hab das letztes mal wieder probiert ok test weiß gar nicht warum die das so verkacken
ihr wisst ich verwende gerne ubuntu aber auf nicht mehr auf dem desktop ich mag ubuntu
auch alle meine server laufen mit ubuntu aber auf dem desktop finde ich total verkackt achso
ja ja sorry wir müssen ich ja ja ich weiß chat wir müssen das ja wie die coolen leute
aussprechen stimmt stimmt ja ubuntu verwende ich ubuntu ubuntu damit ich über meine router
nach zu emerson gehen kann ja genau und dann paar comments im jit einchecken und und natürlich
tickets im gyro aufmachen übrigens dieses desktop markieren ist mein tick wenn ich gerade
keine einzeln kopieren kann dann markier ich desktops übrigens das resizing hat der desktop
nicht wirklich gut überlebt muss ich sagen nee gif sage ich nicht anstatt skiff das ist
mir das sogar das ist sogar mir zu doof wobei man sich darüber streiten kann kann könnte ob
es nicht wirklich gif heißt weil sogar glaube ich der gif mit gif erfinder ab und zu mal gif
gesagt hat und es steht er steht halt für kraft ich weiß nicht wie man auf gif kommt aber ja
was auch immer ist auch wurscht ich sag gif ich sag ja auch immer noch amazon und nicht
emerson gibt es ein netflix programm für mint es sieht fast so aus
was hältst du von archlinux auf dem desktop ja bei normaler linux ist arch by the way
zumindest die art schnupf variante windows 10 auf dem server siebau alter
arco linux ja das wollte ich mir auch demnächst mal angucken windows 10 auf dem server ist besser
als windows auf dem server warum überhaupt windows auf dem server egal in welcher variante das
das fasse ich mit der zange nicht an genau mancharo ist das mancharo mit man das mancharo mit
ihn drei ich habe mich da mittlerweile so drauf eingeschossen ich verwende es genau das gleiche
setup auf der arbeit auf dem notebook bin da schon so dran gewöhnt ich werde auch jetzt nicht
umsteigen wozu hatte ich keinen sinn warum soll ich zwischendurch einfach random umsteigen weil
es immer wieder danach ist irgendwie so es gibt leute die machen das so nach dem auto
oder ich habe jetzt ein halbes halbes jahr die gleiche distro den gleichen desktop verwendet
nee nee nee nee ich muss mal ich muss mal switchen auf was anderes was ich nicht kenne
es heißt ich schütze es heißt ich schütze schitt ja schitt heißt das ja nur bei unserem premium
ja das habe ich mitbekommen ich weiß aber nicht warum du irgendwie 64 kerne oder so was
server haben willst ich mein man kann die genug haben verstehe ich schon aber so genau
habe ich nicht verstanden doch moment sebaru wir probieren jetzt mal auf wie schnell es von hier
lädt frag mich warum das andere ab anderweitig so langsam gelaufen ist gerade geht auch ich weiß
es nicht restart now ex ich bin mal gespannt ob der sich jetzt gemerkt hat dass ich vor
immer tools installiert habe ja ja ich habe ich habe enter gepresst oh mini vmw mini fps
oben in der ecke das ist also wenn ich mal wenn ich mal quasi nachwuchs habt dann ist das mini
fps so nein wir haben keine vmw tools installiert was ist denn das hier ich wusste gar nicht dass
das miniature fps da oben in der ecke hallo ich will das zu machen ok es gibt es gibt ein
problem leute die buttons sind kaputt mein linker maus button geht nicht mein linker maus
button ist kaputt moment geht er unter windows noch unter windows windows geht er noch warum
bei the way warum ist eigentlich die windows bilderanzeige so ein krab und öffnet so langsam
mein link mein linker maus button geht nicht sehr gut sehr gut excellent ok vor allem
tools installieren vielleicht kriegen wir das hin nur mit der rechten maustaste ok wir haben
schon mal deutsch tastatur das schon mal gut ab install open vm tools des des kobe mein
vater hat früher immer des kobe gesagt ich habe dem 100.000 mal erklärt es heißt desktop
und nicht des kobe ich glaube der sagt heute immer noch des kobe wer weiß vielleicht haben
sie die foto apps in elektronen wer weiß wer weiß ach guck mal jetzt geht die linke maustaste
lustig soll klar mal rebooten wow da fack ist hier los gerade das flimmert mir ein bisschen
zu sehr hin und her
des kobe ja jetzt geht die linke maustaste sehr schön you are connected das ist ja nett
dass sie mir das mitteilst leute soll ich euch was sagen für für youtube ich habe
mittlerweile echt eine riesen liste an themen ich habe das problem ich muss mal kurz ich
muss auch gerade was los werden ja das problem was ich mit meinem youtube channel habe ist
teste noch mal wo bloß punkt tb ja kann ich kurz machen
es geht immer noch schnell also das problem was mit meinem youtube channel hab ist wenn
man sich das hier mal so anguckt das ist ja ziemlich unterschiedliches zeug was ich so
von mir gebe ja von irgendwelchen battlefield noobs weihnachtsgeschenken irgendwelche talks
über alles mögliche
das problem was ich hab auf youtube warum ich auch so wenig motivation habe ja ich hab
halt krasse thumbnail skills ja ich das ist auch so was wenn ich wirklich ernsthaft dir
youtube machen würde dann würde ich mir auch jemand suchen der mir thumbnail macht weil
meine thumbnail skills halten sich ja nur wirklich in grenzen das schaut ja echt grausig
aus ja
wobei ich den eigentlich ganz gut finde hier gachi gachi hyper so also mein problem ist
ich hab kein ordentliches konzept was ich machen kann vor allem wo ich kontinuierlich
was machen kann und es muss halt auch irgendwas sein was ich machen kann weiterhin neben
dem dass ich halt arbeiten gehe ja
also ich kann jetzt nicht sagen ich mach jetzt super krass animierte premium videos wo ich
10 tage 10 10 stunden pro video oder 30 stunden pro video mache und so ich bräuchte halt so
eine mischung
aber es ist echt schwierig ich bräuchte irgendwie so ein paar so 4 5 so pfeiler wo ich sagen
kann das sind so die dinger wofür der kanal steht also jetzt ich mein call of duty battlefield
ist es halt nicht mehr spiele ich ja selbst nicht mehr großartig jetzt wieder ein bisschen
battlefield 3 also ich bräuchte so viel von sagen wofür man sagen kann ja dafür steht
der channel das heißt die leute wissen auch worauf die sich einlassen wenn sie den subscriben
an sich habe ich genug aber so wirklich es mangelt mir so irgendwie an konzept
was macht der friseur eigentlich der friseur der ist jetzt du kannst übrigens das video
von ihm gucken da hat letztens ein video gemacht es ist viel besser bevor ich dir das erzähle
guckt ihr einfach das video vom friseur an was er vor einer woche hochgeladen hat
du hast keine eindeutige zielgruppe ja das das beschreibt es auch ganz gut deswegen sage
ich ja dass ich bräuchte irgendwie mal in ein ordentliches konzept und auch so viel
von sachen wofür das ganze steht dann würde ich dann wird mir auch einfacher kontinuierlich
so ein bisschen eins zum anderen kommen ja es ist das ist echt nicht einfach ja und
wenn ich wirklich wieder ernsthaft youtube machen sollte dann würde ich auch mal gucken
dass ich ein bisschen ein bisschen die ganze sache wieder promote also sprich dass man
mal ein paar videos aufnehmen mit ein paar anderen leuten ich kenne ja ich kenne ja glücklicher
weise noch ein paar und kann ja auch mit ein paar leute mal was aufnehmen ja und da würde
ich ja würde ein bisschen ganz ganz wieder ordentlich promoten aber dazu bräuchte ich
erst mal richtig richtig sinniges konzept irgendwie wo ich auch sage ja das ist was
in der art und weise könnte ich mir das vorstellen dass jetzt ein paar jahre zu machen ja fruchtzwerg
so einzelne video dinger bringen ja nix ich brauche ich brauche irgendwie so ich sage
drei vier fünf sachen es ist nicht so einfach zumal man halt auch sagen muss ja ich könnte
weiterhin random über gaming sachen labern ab und zu mal ein bisschen über aktuelle
themen dann über technik sagen das passt aber auch nicht so richtig hundertprozentig
zusammen irgendwie das ist nicht so einfach es ist auch nicht mehr es ist halt auch nicht
mal 2010 ich will keinen kostenlosen shit von den herstellern haben ja das stimmt da
bin ich ja auch froh dass ich viele leute habe die sich das angucken sich über jedes
video freuen aber damit erreichten auch keine neuen leute ich meine ich finde super dass
so viele leute am start sind es dürfte mich nicht falsch verstehen ja aber es muss ja
schon das ziel sein auch zusätzlich noch neue leute zu erreichen ich meine also wenn
ich wenn ich youtube wieder anfangen sollte dann ist auf jeden fall mein erstes ziel ich
will mal 300k voll machen das ist das ist wirklich so das erste ziel was ich dann hätte
erst mal 300k voll machen auf der vorstehung und dazu kommt halt es muss halt auch irgendwo
noch ein bisschen was damit zu tun haben wofür der kanal in der vergangenheit so da war
weil ansonsten könnte ich auch gleich einen neuen channel machen ich kann jetzt nicht
einfach sagen ich mache komplett was anderes was 276k überhaupt nicht interessiert wie
lange arbeitest du schon auf 300k hin muss mich eher fragen wie lange ich da nicht mehr
drauf hin arbeite arbeite seit sechs jahren nicht mehr drauf hin oder seit fünf jahren
oder so mache ich mache ich mache doch seit fünf jahren kaum noch videos ich mache einfach
reaction mit facecam wo ich mich ausblöre oder so ok also jetzt machen wir mit der eigentlich
geschichte weiter übrigens gab noch ein paar fragen im chat wollte ich mal kurz mal ja
bin dank dir auf das ganze it thema aufmerksam geworden ja das ist eine sache das freut mich
das habe ich von vielen schon gehört das schreiben auch viele dass sie wegen mir fachinformatiker
systemintegration gelernt haben und so was das finde ich natürlich immer noch richtig
nice bei einer million facecam macht testet auch magenta scheiß eigentlich eine richtig
gute idee
ich habe mich lange nicht mehr über die bahn ausgelassen stimmt
ich mache prank videos da bin ich genau der richtige channel für prank videos
wollte übrigens mal gucken fällt mir gerade ein ob wie viel amazon easy money das video
schon gebracht hat also gestern waren es 80 euro das weiß ich aber ich würde mich interessieren
jetzt mal ein paar tage später matze 2090 fragt persönliche frage wohnt dein vater
eigentlich nicht mehr bei euch nein schon ewig nicht mehr ich habe mit dem auch kaum was
zu tun und ich bin da eigentlich auch ganz froh drum weil in der regel wenn ich mit ihm
was zu tun habe dann will er geld haben oder hat sich irgendwelche anderen sachen ok ich
erzähle euch jetzt wenn wir gerade bei diesem thema sind ich erzähle euch jetzt mal eine
übelst eine übelst der pains champ ist es nicht wirklich aber eine ich erzähle einfach
ist egal wie man das kann die merkwürdige story und zwar ich habe immer von der jahre
lang schon nichts mal viel nicht mal viel zu tun da meldet sich immer mal bei mir ein
bisschen kohle brauche so und ich mache dabei mal kurz den besten bildschirm schoner aller
zeiten an so und eines tages habe ich eine email im postfach er ist im urlaub er war
im urlaub in irgendwo in der karibik oder so man muss dazu man muss dazu sagen der hat
jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel geld ja da bekommt ein bisschen rente die eigentlich für ihn
mehr als ausreichend ist aber der schafft es halt überhaupt nicht irgendwie insoweit
mit geld umzugehen dass der das bei sich behält ja sobald er sobald er geld am start hat kauft
er sich zwei neue gitarrin oder sowas dann ist gelbe weg naja zumindest der ist in urlaub
gefahren irgendwo in die karibik hat er wahrscheinlich auf großen deutschen macker gemacht wahrscheinlich
wollte er da irgendwelche jungen karibikerinnen oder so davon überzeugen dass ein geiler
hecht ist keine ahnung zumindest habe ich irgendwann eine email bekommen da stand drinnen
er ist war das dominikanische republik oder so ist das karibik glaube das ist karibik
er ist in der dominikanischen republik und er ist er wurde entführt stand in der email
drinnen er wird hier festgehalten er wurde entführt und er braucht löse geld kein witz
das hat er mir per mail geschrieben ich war natürlich schon ein bisschen skeptisch ich
war natürlich schon ein bisschen skeptisch dass der mir eine mail schreiben kann wenn
er angeblich entführt ist das war schon merkwürdig ja so und da habe ich halt zurückgeschrieben
richtig skirmaster eigentlich ja habe ich halt zurückgeschrieben hä wie was was was
ist was los hier hat er gemeint ja er liegt hier irgendwie in der garage und die haben
ihm irgendwie alles geklaut und er braucht jetzt irgendwie 500 euro und nach dem motto
okay wenn du mir wenn du mir eine email schreiben kannst warum schreibst nicht der polizei oder
irgendwie dem dem der botschaft oder irgend wem oder rufst irgendwo an oder sonst wie
also ist irgendwie merkwürdig wenn man ja die botschaft interessiert sich da nicht
dafür ist schon komisch okay na gut weißt du was jetzt hat jetzt keinen sinn da irgendwie
lang drüber zu diskutieren ich gebe dir einfach 500 haben schon 500 euro überwiesen
oder habe ich erstmal nichts mal von ihm gehört war erstmal wieder gut ja das war wieder
nichts von ihm gehört ok und dann danach als er wieder in deutschland war habe ich
raus bekommen was ist der wurde nicht entführt der ist in der karibik ins krankenhaus gegangen
hat sich dort behandeln lassen hat nicht bezahlt und wollte abhauen und die haben ihn
erwischt beim abhauen und dann haben die gesagt hier du bleibst jetzt mal schön da bis du
deine rechnung bezahlt hast der konnte natürlich nicht zu mir und sagen ich habe eine rechnung
ich bin ins krankenhaus bezahlt die rechnung nicht da hat er sich lieber die entführung
story ausgedacht aber warum gibst du ihm überhaupt geld maß der ab das ist eine gute
frage ja da bin ich dann nachher drauf gekommen der wurde nicht entführt oder sonst was der
hat einfach nur offene rechnung gehabt und die haben ihn ein also sagen wir so ein funken
wahrheit haben die stories von ihm immer weil es also eins war tatsächlich die wahrheit
sie haben ihn da nicht weggelassen aber das ist ja auch irgendwie nachvollziehbar ich
würde den auch nicht weglassen wenn er bei mir 500 euro schulden hat doch ich schon aber
wenn ich wenn ich nicht mehr nicht das krankenhaus in der karibik wäre ja ja und solche dinger
mit meiner mutter komm ich gut klar ja und solche dinger ich weiß ehrlich gesagt klochzade
ich weiß gar nicht mal ich glaube habe ich entweder wir haben es von seinem bruder raus
gekriegt oder oder er hat selbst erzählt ich glaube er hat sogar selbst erzählt weil er
gedacht hat es juckt mich nicht mehr oder so also das ist nicht das erste mal dass er
so zeug erzählt ja und deswegen wie gesagt also ich höre von dem in der regel nur was
wenn er wenn er geld braucht und ich bin da auch mittlerweile ehrlich gesagt ganz froh
drum weil ich will mit ihm eigentlich gar nichts mehr großartig zu tun haben in der regel
nervt er plus rum mit irgendwelchen sachen also ja normalerweise wird man eigentlich
davon ausgehen normalerweise sollte es ja umgedreht sein ja dass du als sohn mal zu deinem vater
gehen kannst wenn du probleme hast aber bei uns ist das eher umgedreht deswegen bin ich
eigentlich auch ganz froh solange ich da nix von ihm höre euch wird vielleicht aufgefallen
sein dass ich die überwachungskamera über der über der tür so angebracht habe dass
man es erstens nicht erkennt und zweitens dass ich vom winkel her ganz gut erkenne ob
mein vater vor der tür steht oder nicht die überwachungskamera vor der tür hat genau
diesen zweck ursprünglich gehabt dass ich schon vorher sehe ob mein vater vor der tür
steht also so so so weit sind wir schon ja ich habe kameras installiert dass ich gleich
sehe ob es ist oder nicht eigentlich traurig eigentlich hast du recht hilly ja eigentlich
schon aber mich stört das mittlerweile nicht mehr ja so genug storytime der hat auch mehr
also dinger gerissen also das kannst du keinem erzählen der hat ja mal auch keinem erzählen
der hat ja mal das übelste scam business betrieben in zeiten vorm internet hat er
Leute hat er übelst leute gescampt und gerade das gerade halt auch so alte omas und sowas
wo ich mir halt denke dass es genau die die masche die heute immer noch abgezogen wird
wie alt bist du ich bin 36 das heißt mein vater ist jetzt irgendwie 72 oder so irgendwie
sowas naja aber ist schon ist schon ding telefon scam nein so eine art so eine art partnervermittlung
scam war das der hat der hat irgendwelchen omas erzählt er findet den passenden partner
für sie da hat quasi so eine partnervermittlung aufgemacht hat er zählt hier also das war
noch vorm internet wir reden hier von 1988 bis 1990 oder so ja so und da hat er halt
irgendwelche omas am start gehabt oder was ist omas irgendwelche älteren damen als
kundschaft gehabt und den hat er erzählt wenn sie einen vertrag bei ihm abschließen findet
er halt den optimalen partner für die und was er dann halt gemacht hat ist der hatte
so zwei drei herren die halt gut ausgeschaut haben gut reden konnten halt halt typen auf
die die mädels halt gestanden haben und der hat halt die gleichen drei typen bei allen
frag mich mich 150 damen vorbei geschickt und die haben den schönen augen gemacht und
haben dann halt ihre verdrehe verlängert der hat die richtig hardcore gescampt aber
da bin ich ihm nicht böse weil die leute waren doch schon zum größten teil selbst
daran schuld dass sie sich mit sowas haben scammen lassen der richtig hart da hat die
richtig hardcore gescampt und da war ich zwar noch klein aber ich habe so ein paar sachen
mitbekommen die haben sich teilweise richtig gefreut die haben sich teilweise richtig gefreut
der ist dann der typ ist dann bei denen daheim vorbeigekommen hat dann war tierlieb wenn
sie halt angegeben hat dass der tier lieb sein sollte ja war tierlieb hat hat ihr schöne
augen gemacht hat irgendwie rumgeschleimt und alles die waren richtig happy und haben
dann teilweise echt ein jahresvertrag und sowas abgeschlossen und das muss richtig
teuer gewesen hat ich habe keine ahnung wie viel das wirklich gekostet aber das ging
richtig ins geld ja und dann hat dann hat er mal eine da gehabt die gemeint hat sie
kann das nicht mehr bezahlen sie kann das nicht mehr bezahlen und irgendwie ist das
ist ihr das alles nix aber sie hatte sie hatte noch irgendwie einen langen vertrag
und die haben die richtig krass gescampt damals die haben mir dann erzählt so nach dem motto
ja das ist ja auch problematisch uns entstehen ja da auch jetzt hohe kosten durch und aber
weil sie frau müller so sehr mögen darf frau müller jetzt aus dem vertrag raus und muss
nur noch drei monate bezahlen also quasi die durfte jetzt raus musste aber noch drei monats
dinger bezahlen so krass gescampt wie die die leute haben es echt der wahnsinn dass sie
da mitgemacht haben es hat keiner gecheckt ein paar haben ihn auch angezeigt danach aber
ist nichts passiert ist nichts passiert weil die verträge waren schon wasserdicht das
also muss sagen scammen kann er also wer also möchte ich wirklich nee nee das ist das
wurde sogar verhandelt vollkornmischbrot das wurde sogar verhandelt also da ist nichts
mehr nichts mehr zu holen in der richtung das wurde sogar verhandelt alles die verträge
waren wasserdicht und die leute waren einfach nur zu doof und angeblich ich war bei der
gerichtsverhandlung nicht dabei angeblich hat der richter eine eine von den kundinnen
gefragt warum haben sie denn sowas unterschrieben das muss also wohl offensichtlich das scam
gewesen sein warum haben sie sowas denn unterschrieben tja das war halt noch oldschool scam das war
noch richtig oldschool scam pre internet ja also wenn ich jemanden wenn ich jemand suchen
würde der leute scammen kann dann würde ich als erstes zu meinem vater gehen der ist skammasmeister
leider hat er glaube ich ein bisschen den anschluss verloren was internet und sowas
angeht naja ja leute deswegen weiß ich auch wie es ist eine hausdurchsuchung zu haben
und so und andere geschichten das habe ich alle schon hinter mir wegen meinem vater also
insofern tja das hat vor gericht standgehalten ja ja ich kann mich noch dran erinnern wo
ich klein war war auf einmal unsere haustür auf als wir heimgekommen sind und die polizei
war am start und die haben halt bei uns die sachen die alten sachen von meinem vater also
die noch in der wohnung von meiner mutter damals waren durchsucht wegen dieser geschichte
und aber letztendlich sie haben ja auch nichts gefunden weil dafür ist ihm nichts passiert
das wäre doch ein youtube video na ich will das nicht so breit reden es ist ihm nichts
passiert wegen der scam geschichte es ist ihm wegen anderen sachen was passiert aber
nicht wegen aber nicht wegen scam so aber jetzt kommen wir zu der eigentlichen eigentlichen
geschichte zurück warum wir hier sind ich wollte mir die lux mit angucken hab den anfang
nicht mitgekommen mit was wurde gescampt ich habe erzählen dass mein vater früher präinternet
leute gescampt hat mit so einer art partnervermittlung hat er leute gescampt und richtig und richtig
hardcore so was von gescampt die leute waren so blöden haben damit gemacht kannst du uns
die verträge mal schicken nein habe ich nicht keine ahnung oder würde ich auch nicht machen
ist fischtell genauso gut wie zsh kommt darauf an was ihr lieber ist ich glaube das nimmt
sich da alles nicht so viel ich muss ja persönlich sagen ich habe fisch nie großartig verwendet
da viel bei dir der apfel aber weit vom stamm ja ist so also was das angeht gut aber
das liegt glaub auch daran meine mutter ist da komplett entgegengesetzt also sprich ich
habe so beides ja ich also ich merke dass wenn ich so meine wenn ich so meine fünf
minuten habe also dass ich hier beispielsweise einsen kopier wie verrückt und dass ich dann
hier erzählen das ist der pokers huge huge keck weh und sonst was so zeug habe ich also
dumm zeug labern habe ich eindeutig von meinem vater aber die restlichen sachen habe ich
ja oder deswegen scam ich auch keine leute zum beispiel kein skam asia ich muss ja auch
kein scam ich muss ja auch kein scam ich kriege ja genug prime subs auch ohne zu scam
ihr kennt die scam aktion nicht ja das kann natürlich auch sein
sachen gibt es schön gibt es sich hier auf den schmach weiter so 1,5 billionen euro lego
moment donation wtf brain lag 15 euro so ungefähr sind quasi drei prime subs massive und massiv
viele emotes benutzt du youtube advanced ja mache ich auf dem android tablet welche virtualisierung
das ist vor allem ein workstation so ok genug von meinem vater erzählt machen wir weiter
oh man die meisten sachen habe ich ja schon voll verdrängt die meisten erfahren wir schon
gar nicht mehr ein so wie spielst du den nice sound ab du meinst den hier lizenz gekauft
lizenz gekauft offiziell ich war dumm ich habe dafür für die hier perversion habe
ich direkt bei vmware gekauft und für vmware workstation 16 habe ich mir bei software kong
eine lizenz bestellt ich hoffe ich wurde nicht gescampt den sound spiele ich folgendermaßen
ab warum wird was blockiert seit wann blockt er denn was von meinen was blocken der sieht
man das irgendwie was der blockt warum blockt der localhost sieht man was er genau blockt
blockt und ist page 1 ich habe das ja nie vor sieht man das jetzt auf dem dashboard und
vorletzter button openlogger ahja ah signal a blockter warum macht er denn so was das ist
localhost warum blockt der localhost irgendwas na gut zack jetzt gehts wieder komisch warum
blockt der lokale requests was das für zeug und wie kann ich das jetzt überhaupt freigeben
das ist bestimmt ein bug das ist bestimmt ein bug excellent naja gut zumindest wie ich
den sound auslöse hier drüber ich habe mir so ein board programmiert wo du emotes einblenden
kannst ja und da klicke ich halt drauf vom anderen rechner raus ok aber jetzt gucken
wir uns die ganze sache mal an ich habe jetzt ganz ganz schön lang rum gelabert also was
haben wir anstatt mich dabei also wie gesagt wo ich das letzte mal linux mint verwendet
habe ich schon ganz lang her aber eine sache die mir da auch ganz gut gefallen hat ist
dass die ein nicht so überschüttet haben mit 30 milliarden verschiedenen programm sondern
hauptsächlich eins für einen zweck und halt auch warten sehen sich ziemlich ähnlich
und halt auch meistens ganz gute hast du das neue z plus plus update schon gesehen und
sie betest mich oder das hast du das letzte mal schon erzählt das ist hier ja langsam
falle ich da nicht mehr drauf rein das sagte jeden striem ja also was haben wir dabei was
ist da mich für den text edit oder das ist hier geedit oder was zum teuer ist das überhaupt
habe ich nie gesehen also was haben wir denn sonst hier alles dabei das startmenü verwirrt
mich schon mal hier all applications ich habe youtube vanst aber das heißt nix jeder soll
da verwenden was er will also was haben wir hier vor installiert standards jubantu geschichten
graphics pics drawing ja guck mal mal ist das standardmessiges bild dabei wo man mal was
ausprobieren könnte dann png lad schon mal ein keks runter
guck mal hier plus size sweaters die wissen bescheid
was zum
bettel viel erhöht hannah schön dazu habe ich garantiert nichts gemacht
wie jetzt ist ja wie öffne ich hier ist er nautilus drauf nee was für ein file manager
ist da dabei kaia habe ich noch nie gehört kaia ich nehme es ist kaia so downloads und
da ist mein bild ok wer p ist noch nicht angekommen alles klar ok dann lade ich jetzt den max
fps logo alter ich habe angst vor monka tost was wird in links immer angezeigt
das video mit max fps wer ist das mit wem habe ich da was gemacht
der mathematiker ok gibt es das hier als png jetzt ok keksor png excellent geht der hier
darf man den aufmachen ok das mag ich ja schon mal nicht dass man
nicht direkt auf den close button kommt wenn man oben in die ecke geht so also wer p geht
schon mal net das ist schon mal ein bisschen doof ne ich meine wer p ist jetzt wirklich
nichts neues probieren wir das doch mal aus
was ist das wieder für eine usability yes vielleicht vielleicht doch nicht ok das mag
ich ja schon mal net was hatte hier unten für schmerzen update manager excellent alles
klar vielleicht muss ich den update manager erst mal einrichten dass es funktioniert
erst mal paketquellen aktualisieren wir geben ihm da noch mal eine chance brings nice so
viele leute am start sind es lag wahrscheinlich an storytime gerade install updates jawoll
ja guck wie schnell sowas geht hier am internet veramt blub am internetanschluss kann es
ja nicht liegen geht schnell
gerade für das erwähnen der lizenz hast du hast du dir auch bei software kong was
gekauft das war 2014 schon ernst da wo wir mario kart gespielt haben ja wie gesagt so
lange mache ich schon keine videos mehr richtig
standardmäßig hatte dps geschmack ganz stark von aus wird mich ganz würde mich wundern
wenn ich warte mal wo sieht man das hier kann man wahrscheinlich gerade nicht machen
hast du tips wie ich es hinbekomme es die scharp zu verstehen ich bin da irgendwie zu
blöd für ja jeder hin und guckt ihr das buch an bis zu kapitel 16
stimmt was das denn tatsächlich
gut sagen wir mal so pakete runterladen über htp ist jetzt nicht so problematisch da ist
er wird er hoffentlich mal checksum check gemacht danach aber wundert mich trotzdem
dass es über htp und ich hatte dps kannst du von dem youtube tritt schon mal nie ein
schleben
hatte ich nicht mach ja nix also als ich noch viel gemacht habe und als auch noch viele
geguckt haben und als ich noch irgendwie wusste was ich was ich an content bringen soll und
als es auch noch leute interessiert hat weil ich nicht sechs jahre inaktiv war da hätte
ich wahrscheinlich von leben können hätte ich mir sehr laut gemacht ja habe ich aber
nie
das buch hatte noch gedruckt davon ja das ist auch nicht schlecht also wie gesagt das
buch aber nur bis kapitel 12 danach ist sinnlos also hier bis was für komische pdf from china
fack ja ich mein warum ist da jahoo suche fällt mir ja gerade ein was ist denn mit denen
los warum denn um alles in der welt die jahoo suche das müssen wir klein mal umstellen
search
komm mal man kann duck duck man kann kein google mehr auswählen das haben sie raus
geworfen aber ob da jahu jetzt so viel besser ist weiß ich nicht
0w jetzt sucht er auf duck duck go ok ach jahu sponsored mit ok dann verstehe ich die
haben wahrscheinlich gesagt jahu rein google raus
das hier ist duck duck go ne also wie gesagt bis bis kapitel 12 ne bis kapitel 16
danach musste musste nicht mehr angucken aber dann hast du schon mal ganz guten überblick
und das ist somit das beste kostenlose buch so haben wir jetzt die updates installiert
das ist auch eine sache wo ich man jahoo echt zu schätzen weiß die updates sind halt
übel schnell guckt euch das mal an ich gucke mal ob es jetzt updates gerade gibt
zackig und hier krebst er ewig rum, aber das bei Ubuntu ja normal
Auf Machine! Oh Walken-Treiber! Die brauchen wir in VM natürlich unbedingt
So, während das installiert gucken wir uns das ganze noch mal an. Haben die jetzt mittlerweile so eine Standard App dabei?
Okay, ich kann es mit Image Viewer öffnen oder mit PIX Image Viewer. Was ist ein Unterschied?
X Viewer oder mit PIX Image Viewer
Okay, das wird mich jetzt schon mal verwirren, warum es da zwei Sachen gibt
Kann man denn damit irgendwie so ein bisschen Sachen machen wie Bilder zurechtschneiden oder so?
Die Icons, die, ey, oh ne, ich soll ja mal was sagen, die Standard Gnome Icons, so kacke, da sind die Material Design Icons sogar richtig gut dagegen
Bist du eigentlich Ingenieur, ähm, weißt du ob ich ein Diplom hab oder so? Nö
Aber brauche ich nicht, ich bin Twitch Ingenieur, ich hab in den Twitch Tags Ingenieurswesen drin stehen, also ist das ja quasi schon gleich bedeutend mit Abschluss
Ja, also ich muss sagen, also die Gnome Icons sind wirklich Müll. So, und kann ich hier irgendwie was beschneiden drin oder so? Nee, das geht damit nicht, das ist wirklich nur zum Viewen
Und wie sieht es mit dem PIX Image Viewer aus? Kann ich da irgendwas beschneiden?
Also die Standard Icons sind wirklich abadisch hier. Du musst echt über jedes Icon drüber, dass du erkennst, was es ist
Ok, Convert Image, Resize Image kann man machen. Na, Katz willst du rein? Nein
So, Katz ist am Start. Wie alt ist die Katz? Ich glaube 11. Also was kann man jetzt machen? Links, rechts rotieren, exellent. So und Resize. Oh nee, ernsthaft?
Das ist ja das schlechteste, oh Gott. Ich dachte man kann wenigstens das dynamisch machen mit Ausschneiden oder so. Ich mein wer resize denn so?
Nee, oder? Das ist ja mal 1998, lässt grüßen. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Also Trash, Trash, komplett Trash
Komplett Trash, ah guck mal der kann WebP. Reboot required. Ok, guck mal WebP das ist aber nicht mit PIX verknüpft. Kann ich PIX hier wenigstens auswählen?
PIX. Eww, MonkaS. Alter was ist denn mit euch los, sag mal. Ich will einfach nur Bilder anzeigen. Ok, ich bin nicht beeindruckt bisher.
Ich bin nicht begeistert. Ok, wir rebooten mal, es will dass ich reboote. Rebooten wir mal. Du kannst es mit Drawing öffnen.
Wie oft in deinem Leben dachtest du darüber nach einen völlig anderen Job zu machen? Gar nicht. Du würdest am liebsten Förster werden. Ah, exellent.
Ja, Förster ist sicherlich nice wenn man auf Natur steht, ja. Nein, ich hab ehrlich gesagt noch nie darüber nachgedacht einen anderen Job zu machen, weil ich hab davor, bevor ich die Ausbildung gemacht hab, mich in was anderem versucht und das war übelster Schrott. Deswegen.
Maxi wäre es mit einem Linux From Scratch nach dem Cobalt Stream. Der Chat will mich leiden sehen. Worum gehts gerade? Ich guck mir Linux Mint an und ich bin nicht begeistert bisher. In Downloads.
Das ist echt hässlich. Das ist echt eines der. Und jetzt, was hab ich jetzt gemacht? Jetzt hab ich es kaputt gemacht, guck mal. Installiere mal Arch Linux. Also Manjaro haben wir im Stream schon installiert, nämlich das was ich hier verwende.
Was zum Teufel ist das? Okay, wenn es schon dran scheitert Bilder zu öffnen, dann weiß ich auch nicht. In Drawing soll ich es öffnen, okay. Das ist Paint, es ist Paint.
Das ist Paint 2. Okay, also Web, das kann auch kein Web M. Kann das, Keksauerkanz. Okay, das ist Paint nur noch noch schlechter.
Oh Gott, ich muss das zu machen, ich krieg Anfälle. Discard, weg damit, Alter. Okay, okay, sehr gut. C++ Stream, schon wieder hatten wir doch erst vor einem halben Jahr, reicht auch.
C++ Schrott Stream, Alter. CentOS wird jetzt Rolling Release. Was? Wie wolltest du das denn machen?
Kannst du mal ein gescheites Buildsystem für C++, ich werde mich hüten, also könnte ich auch gar nicht, mich hüten auch nur einen Finger krumm zu machen was C++ angeht, wenn ich nicht dazu gezwungen bin.
Und die einzigen Sachen wo ich halt C++ machen muss, ist halt wenn ich ESP-2866, ESP-32 Zeug programmieren, da geht halt nur C++ richtig.
Okay, CentOS wird Rolling Release, ja da bin ich ja mal gespannt, das muss ich mal kurz angucken.
Jetzt können wir mal gucken wie gut sich das für den Alltag eignet hier, also.
Was wollen wir denn? Future CentOS Project ist, also was man wissen muss, Nummer 2 Erklärung. Schau dir mal QView an, kann ich machen?
Nummer 2 Erklärung was CentOS ist, vielleicht sagt das nicht jedem was. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass Red Hat Linux werden die meisten Leute kennen bzw. den Namen schon mal gehört haben.
Red Hat ist eigentlich so der größte Linux Konzern, Linux Laden, den es so gibt.
Was, nach was soll ich kommen? QView? Gibt's nicht, null. Gibt's im Paketmanager nicht.
Es gibt Mark QView. Für Gensequenzen, ja alles klar.
Wurde von IBM gekauft. Ich glaube Red Hat wurde letztens an irgendwas, ja es kann sein, dass das IBM war. Ja, genau.
Also das es mit der größten Linux Laden den zu gibt bzw. mit einer der bekanntesten und die haben eine Linux Distribution die halt im Enterprise Bereich sehr beliebt ist.
Nämlich Red Hat Enterprise Linux. R-H-I-L. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Und bei Red Hat ist es halt so, du kannst das Betriebssystem theoretisch schon kostenlos verwenden, aber du kriegst keine Updates.
Oder nur um Umwege. Also die möchten, dass du dich, dass du das lizenzierst.
Dementsprechend bekommst du halt aber auch Support wenn du das lizenzierst. Das Zeug ist aber nicht billig.
Da bezahlt es glaube ich 200 Euro pro System oder irgendwie sowas. Müssen wir mal gucken.
Pricing.
Da oben müssen wir mal gucken.
Oh, ist teurer geworden.
Also guck.
Also man bezahlt.
Man bezahlt 350 Euro. Ist das pro Server?
Moment, Moment. Self Support ein Jahr 350 Euro. Warum sollte ich das denn machen?
What?
Das heißt, was bekomme ich denn überhaupt für 350 Euro?
Hä? What the fuck? Okay, ich bekomme die Red Hat Updates.
Das ist alles. Ich bekomme die Updates. Genau.
So, zumindest.
Diese Sache ist im Enterprise Umfeld sehr beliebt.
Nachdem der Kram allerdings scheiß teuer ist, machen es die meisten Leute so.
Sie installieren CentOS. CentOS ist quasi ein Red Hat ohne Red Hat.
Die nehmen eins zu eins, weil ich meine, Linux ist immer noch Open Source.
Und von den Lizenzen her ist es quasi erforderlich, dass Red Hat, auch wenn sie hier Pay to Win macht,
die Sachen immer noch als Source Code zur Verfügung stellt.
Das heißt CentOS geht hin, nimmt den Source Code von Red Hat und baut daraus CentOS.
CentOS ist quasi ein Red Hat, halt nur ohne, dass es 350 Euro kostet.
Und das ist auch im Enterprise Umfeld sehr, sehr beliebt.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit zum Beispiel nahezu alle Systeme sind CentOS.
So, und es gibt ein paar, ich weiß das, weil ich da schon von vielen gehört habe,
auch auf ein paar Schulungen schon von Leuten, die aus ganz anderen Bereichen kommen.
Also aus ganz anderen Ecken auch von Deutschland.
Es ist wohl Gang und Gebe, dass man CentOS verwendet und nur ein paar Red Hat Support Verträge abschließt.
Und wenn man dann einen Support Fall hat, haben halt zufälligerweise immer diese 5 Systeme Probleme.
Also sprich, man hat 100 Server mit CentOS und 5 Systeme mit richtig gutem Support.
Und wenn auf diesen 100 Servern was kaputt geht, dann versucht man das,
einem der 5 Systeme in die Schuhe zu schieben, die Support haben.
Und macht dann halt ein Ticket bei Red Hat.
Also das scheint wohl Gang und Gebe zu sein.
Da haben wir zufälligerweise immer die Red Hat Systeme Probleme.
Naja, und das funktioniert allerdings auch ganz gut, weil eben CentOS,
bis auf die Logos und solche Sachen, ein mehr oder weniger 1 zu 1 Nachbau von Red Hat ist.
Deine Meinung zu Suze? Ich hasse Suze, ey. Ich krieg Anfälle, wenn ich Suze verwenden muss.
Yast war mal cool, aber mittlerweile ist es voll, äh, wie sagt man heute, fühl ich nicht mehr.
Also Yast fühl ich nicht mehr, richtiger Schmutzdigger.
Yast.
Bane's Champ.
Ist nicht Fedora die Entwicklungsumgebung von Red Hat? Ja, so ungefähr.
Fedora ist quasi die unstable Distribution, nennen wir es mal, von Red Hat.
Und viele Sachen aus Fedora kommen über lange Sicht in Red Hat rein.
Welche Oberfläche benutzt du bei Manjaro? I3. I3 only.
Genau, Fedora ist das, was die meisten auf dem Desktop verwenden.
So, genau, so viel zu Red Hat. Und deswegen, bevor wir uns jetzt den Blogpost angucken,
muss man halt wissen, dass CentOS im Enterprise Business Umfeld echt ein großes Ding ist, genauso wie Red Hat.
So, also, was machen sie? Also, Zukunft des CentOS-Projekts, was die Zukunft des CentOS-Projekts ist, CentOS Stream.
Echt unglückliche Bezeichnung für einen Rolling Release, oder?
Ich verstehe, warum sie Stream nennen, aber Stream ist irgendwie schon ein bisschen anderweitig.
Stream? Twitch? Ah, ja, ja. Ist das jetzt neues Betriebssystem von Twitch?
Also Stream finde ich nicht gut. Wo ist die Musik schon wieder aus?
So, also Future ist Stream. So, über das nächste Jahr werden sie ihren Fokus verschieben von CentOS Linux,
also sprich dem Red Hat Nachbau, zu CentOS Stream. Ach ja, man muss auch noch eine Sache wissen,
was Red Hat und CentOS angeht. Nachdem das ja ein mehr oder weniger eins zu eins Nachbau aus dem Red Hat
Source Code ist, bedeutet das auch, dass die Sicherheitspatches von Red Hat übernehmen können.
Und, noch viel wichtiger, Software, die offiziell nur Red Hat supportet, läuft auch unter CentOS.
Und auch Binary-Sachen, die für Red Hat gemacht sind, laufen unter CentOS.
Das ist halt echt ein riesen Vorteil. So, also, ähm...
Was wollen sie? Which tracks just ahead of the current? Den Satz habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ah, CentOS Stream ist quasi vom Software-Stand vorne raus vor Red Hat.
Okay, also sprich, man bekommt jetzt mit CentOS Stream neuere Pakete, als die, die in Red Hat dabei sind.
Das ist ja erstmal prinzipiell nichts verkehrtes, weil ein Problem von Red Hat ist tatsächlich,
das wird zwar ewig supportet, ich meine, Red Hat 6 oder Red Hat 5 wird glaube ich jetzt erst aus dem Support raus.
Oh ne, ist schon ein bisschen hier. Extended Support, ja. Genau, das war, hatte ich irgendwas im Hinterkopf.
Also sprich, Extended Support von 2007, 13 Jahre, das ist jetzt erst raus. So, und 6 geht noch bis 2024.
Das weiß ich, weil CentOS 6 haben wir auch viele Kisten, deswegen weiß ich, dass es bis 2024 geht.
Also da muss ich mir überlegen, die Dinger sind wirklich 14 Jahre, also die werden verdammt lang supportet.
So, und jetzt könnt ihr euch mal vorstellen, dass die Software, die da mitgeliefert wird,
halt nicht gerade das Alleraktuellste ist, ja.
Das hält sich in Grenzen, sagen wir mal so.
So, die meisten unserer Sachen auf der Arbeit sind Red Hat 7 und das wird noch eine ganze Weile supportet.
Wir haben aber auch noch ein paar Red Hat 6 Kisten, deswegen weiß ich, dass wir, wir haben noch ein paar Red Hat 6 Kisten,
deswegen weiß ich, dass es bis 2024 geht und das meiste ist Red Hat 7.
Ja, also man sieht, das wird lange supportet, dementsprechend muss man aber auch hier sehen,
dass auch von Red Hat 7 die Software schon ganz schön alt ist.
Ja, also wenn beispielsweise ein aktuelles PHP braucht, der hat gelitten.
Es gibt so ein paar Zusatzrepos von Red Hat, weiß gar nicht jetzt aus dem Kopf, wie die Dinger heißen,
da gibt es ab und zu mal ein paar aktualisierte Sachen, aber es hält sich echt in Grenzen.
Das ist halt wirklich ein Problem, deswegen ist die Idee von CentOS quasi ein weiteres CentOS rauszubringen,
was nicht eins zu eins Red Hat ist, sondern neuere Sachen beinhaltet, eigentlich gar nicht so verkehrt.
Wo arbeitest du bei der Bank?
Skill Pro, ich lese mir das gleich im Chat durch, wenn ich den Blogpost hier fertig habe.
CentOS Linux 8, das ist natürlich ein dickes Ding, das ist natürlich echt ein dickes Ding.
Also quasi ihr Red Hat 8 Nachbau stellen sie ein Ende 2021.
Okay, das ist wirklich dick, huge ist das, massive.
Also was sollen wir denn da machen jetzt?
Also ich frag mich ernsthaft, was sollen denn jetzt Firmen machen, die das verwenden?
Die jetzt alle 53 Euro pro Server bezahlen oder was?
Die Leute verwenden es ja gerade, weil sie eigentlich Red Hat verwenden wollen.
Das ist mit Migration gar nicht mal so einfach, vor allem nicht, wenn man jede Menge Custom Software hat
oder eingekaufte Software, die nur spezielle Sachen unterstützt, irgendwelche Oracle-Dinger mit einer speziellen Version.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Na gut, also die sagen, danach gibt es weiter, ach so, okay, jetzt verstehe ich, was die machen.
Die nehmen CentOS 8, was aktuell gerade ein 1 zu 1 Nachbau von Red Hat Enterprise Linux 8 ist
und überführen das in CentOS Stream, also quasi, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, aus CentOS 8 wird quasi CentOS Stream.
Okay, das wäre ja noch ein bisschen weniger nervig.
Okay, also sie wollen Red Hat 7 weiter maintainen, das ist schon mal für uns ganz gut.
Oh, Serious Mags sagt, ihr habt 3 CentOS-Kisten, wir haben 4000 CentOS-Kisten.
Die sind nur mal so eingeworfen. Also ich glaube, wir haben da noch ein paar andere Probleme, die da auf uns zukommen.
Wir hatten schon mal mit dem Gedanken gespielt vor ein paar Jahren, dass wir Scientific Linux verwenden.
Das ist nämlich auch ein Red Hat Nachbau, aber das hatte dann auch irgendwelche Probleme, dass es nicht mehr ordentlich supportet wird.
Na gut, wenn ihr nur 10 Mann seid, dann ist natürlich keine Frage.
Also CentOS Stream will also be centerpiece of a major shift in collaboration.
Was zum Geier ist die CentOS Special Interest Group?
SIX
Okay, das heißt, sie werden im Endeffekt CentOS Stream zu so einer Art Testing, ne wie soll man das sagen,
so einer Preview Version vom nächsten Red Hat Enterprise Streams.
Also sowas, was in Debian Testing ist im Endeffekt.
Also im Prinzip sowas, was ein bisschen was in Debian Testing ist.
Was das beste OS ist von Umbrell, kenne ich nicht.
Umbrell Linux klingt jetzt, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Hat irgendwas mit Bitcoin zu tun.
Umkaloabo Linux, genau, umkaloabo.
So, ich gucke gleich in den Chat rein, wenn ich das hier durch habe.
Okay, das ist aber, das ist nicht so geil.
Naja, also ich habe da ehrlich gesagt wenig Confusion gehabt, was CentOS meint.
Für mich war CentOS immer ein RHEL Nachbau.
Okay, also wenn CentOS 8 endet, your best option will be to migrate CentOS Stream 8.
Okay, das heißt, die nehmen die Basis von Red Hat 8 und machen dann quasi den neuesten Shit rein,
der dann irgendwann mal in Red Hat 9 wird oder so.
Mal gucken, wie die Comments ausfallen.
This is dump.
Guck mal, Rocky Linux ist Community Enterprise.
Okay, vielleicht steigen wir auf Rocky Linux um, mal gucken.
Die Sache ist halt die, es ist immer ein bisschen schwierig zu verkaufen das Ganze.
Selbst wenn es exakt das gleiche sein sollte, erkläre mal einem Stonksmensch,
warum du umsteigen musst von CentOS auf Rocky Linux und Rocky Linux ist quasi erst ein Tag alt.
Das kannst du keinem erklären.
Außerdem weiß man auch nicht, ob das wirklich Bestand haben wird.
Okay.
Also die Leute sind abgefuckt, wenn ich mir das angucke.
Was für Vorteile gibt es gegenüber Debian?
Naja, rein jetzt mal aus Adminsicht und so ist es egal, was du verwendest.
Es ist aber so, dass viele Software halt zertifiziert ist für Red Hat.
Viele Oracle-Dinger beispielsweise mögen Red Hat.
Und dass viele Sachen im Enterprise-Umfeld eben auf diesem Red Hat-Ökosystem basieren.
Und dafür ist es halt kacke.
Für dich im privaten Umfeld oder für uns ist das wurscht.
Ja, okay.
Kann ich verstehen, dass die Leute abgefuckt sind?
Okay, ich habe ja gesagt, ich beantworte kurz Chat.
Also, ja, habe ich schon gesehen.
Rocky Linux ist ein Scam.
Ist das so?
Weiß ich nicht, ob das so ist.
Wie kommst du drauf?
Das sieht jetzt erst mal serious aus.
Okay, also, Chat, ich wollte euch irgendwas beantworten.
Ist nicht eigentlich Fedora das Testing von Red Hat?
Ja, so ungefähr.
Fedora ist so die Desktop-Distribution, wo vieles halt auch später mal in Red Hat reinkommt.
Also, der Dude, der CentOS entwickelt, der macht jetzt Rocky Linux, ja.
Genau, deswegen denke ich auch nicht, dass es ein Scam ist.
Ich wollte noch eben Sachen, noch eben was beantworten.
Chat.
Ja, kann sein, dass das eingestellt wurde.
Das hatten wir auch schon mal.
Hä?
Ich habe doch eben gerade in den Chat geguckt und da war was drin, wo ich gesagt habe, da
wollte ich was zu beantworten.
Also, ich scroll noch mal hoch.
Wie kann ich mir bei WireGuard anzeigen lassen, welche Clients verbunden?
Keine Ahnung.
Olaibomster, gute Frage.
Er fragt, wie schwer wäre es bei euch, auf zum Beispiel Arch umzusteigen, auf Server?
Das kannst du vergessen.
Also, sofern ich Arch auf dem Desktop habe, auf dem Server ist das ein bisschen schwierig.
Das Ding ist nämlich, dass viele Software da nicht in den Standard-Paket-Quellen drin
ist, sondern halt über User-Repos kommt und das willst du ehrlich gesagt nicht auf dem
Server haben.
Ja.
Außerdem ist Arch prinzipiell eher so ein Pleading Edge, immer das Neueste.
Rolling System, das ist für Server nicht unbedingt die beste Lösung.
Außerdem wisst ihr, was bei uns ein Riesenakt wäre?
Mal angenommen, wir würden jetzt wirklich sagen, wir steigen auf Ubuntu um oder wir
steigen auf Arch um oder so.
Sagen wir mal, wir steigen auf Ubuntu um.
Das wäre ja noch eine naheliegende Option, wenn Red Hat bzw.
CentOS nicht mehr da ist in der jetzigen Form, was ein Riesenakt werden würde.
Wir haben ja total viele Server-Automatisierungen am Start.
Wir haben zehntausende Sachen, die halt aktuell nur auf Red Hat laufen.
Wie viel davon jetzt eins zu eins auf Ubuntu einfach mal so geht.
Ja, das ganze Server-Provisioning Zeug und sowas.
Das ist ein Riesenakt, das alles anzupassen.
So.
Rocky Leanoch schreiben jetzt ganz viele im Chat.
Ja, ich werde das mal beobachten.
So, das Skiller Pro hat doch vorhin noch irgendwas gefragt.
Wie gesagt, ich arbeite bei einer Bank.
Also Skiller Pro fragt, ich habe.
Ich versuche mal, ob ich die Chat-Nachricht hier aufmachen kann.
Skiller Pro, da ist er.
Ich habe einen lokalen Web-Server auf meiner VM laufen und kann mit
Local Host darauf zugreifen im Browser.
Ist das irgendwie möglich?
What the fuck?
Ist das hier?
Ist es irgendwie möglich, dass ich auf meinem Host auch drauf zugreifen kann?
Ja, das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Also die erste Sache ist, du musst gucken, auf was deine VM eingestellt ist.
Du hast hier unten, also ich zeige es jetzt mal nur stellvertretend für VM-Workstation.
Aber ja, das ist kein Problem.
Das ist möglich und das macht man auch normalerweise so.
Also das ist nichts Außergewöhnliches, was du haben willst.
Also du musst als erstes mal gucken, was du für Netzwerk-Settings hast.
Bei VM-Workstation kannst du das hier einstellen.
Bridged, not Host-Only.
Und wenn du Bridged verwendest, heißt das, deine VM kriegt von einem Router per DHCP
ganz normal eine Adresse und ist dann in deinem Netzwerk erreichbar wie ein eigener Computer.
Das heißt, das müsstest du da einstellen und deine VM mal eine IP beziehen lassen.
Wenn du einfach nur von deinem Host auf die VM zugreifen willst,
dann musst du dir die IP von deiner VM raussuchen und im Browser eingeben bei dir auf dem Host.
Das sollte eins zu eins ohne Änderungen gehen.
Die zweite Variante ist, es könnte natürlich sein, dass du deinen Webserver so gestartet hast,
dass er nur lokal auf deiner VM am Loopback-Interface auf Verbindung wartet.
Dann geht das nicht, dann musst du das erst umstellen.
Was nutzt ihr da? Ansible Chef, CF Engine.
Hauptsächlich Puppet, weil wir das seit 10 Jahren ungefähr schon verwenden.
Ja doch, kommt ungefähr hin.
Ja 8, 9 Jahre vielleicht. Das ist hauptsächlich noch Puppet.
Aber wir haben da massig Zeug drin.
Genau, gut, kommen wir mal zurück zu Linux Mint.
Jetzt haben wir uns das hier angeguckt mit Red Hat.
Ich habe hier gerade Urlaub, ich habe hier quasi schon seit dem 18. November Urlaub.
Und ich habe hier auch noch Urlaub bis nächstes Jahr.
Also das geht noch ein bisschen.
Mich würde interessieren, was gerade auf der Arbeit los ist, als sie das gelesen haben.
Mit CentOS.
Das ist ja auch vor 4 Tagen gepostet worden.
Also widmen uns mal wieder Linux Mint.
Also wir haben neu gestartet.
Ich habe festgestellt, dass die mitgelieferten Programme für Bilder totaler Crap sind.
Aber zum Glück juckt mich das nicht.
Ich meine, ich benutze das ja nicht für Bildbearbeitung.
Das kackt irgendwie ab, das macht gar nichts.
Ist schon länger bekannt.
Ich weiß halt nicht, ob das die Leute bei uns so sehr verfolgen, was da bei CentOS abgeht.
Zum Glück, naja, da weiß ich jetzt nicht, wer da zuletzt lacht.
Guck mal hier.
Wir haben darüber gelacht auf der Arbeit.
Zum Glück letztes Jahr Exit gemacht auf Windows Only.
Da weiß ich nicht, wo man mehr drüber lachen kann.
Windows Only ist ja mal Panes Champ hoch 10.
Ich meine, es gibt Dinge, da bietet sich das an, Windows Only zu machen.
Zum Beispiel fragt mich die Microsoft SQL oder sowas.
Aber Windows Only ist halt echt keck weh.
Siehst du, Zwiebelschick hat auch ein paar am Start.
Ja, so wird es bei uns auch gerade sein.
So, was können wir sonst noch schönes uns angucken?
Also ich hatte doch mal irgendwie so einen Linux.
Ich hatte doch mal hier so eine Liste, was wir uns bei neuen Linux Distributionen alles angucken müssen.
Hold.
Linux Bewertung, da steht es doch.
Also was können wir ausprobieren?
Noob-Freundlichkeit install.
Ja, der Installer war wirklich noob-freundlich.
Look and feel responsive.
Okay, also man muss sagen, es ist ja nur in einer VM.
Dementsprechend kann ich jetzt da keine großartige Aussage drüber treffen,
wie sich Linux Mint anfühlt auf echter Hardware.
Aber für eine VM und für das, dass das ein richtig vollwertiger Desktop ist, fühlt sich das ziemlich gut und schnell an.
Muss man wirklich sagen.
Also vollkommen in Ordnung.
Jetzt hängt es, warum auch immer.
Gut benutzbar.
Sogar der Browser ist schnell.
Also da kann ich mich nicht drüber beschweren.
YouTube in der VM ist unfair.
YouTube in der VM funktioniert prinzipiell nicht ordentlich, weil es keine...
Jaja, ist gut, weil es keine...
Das ist Monkathos erstmal.
Musik.
Was machen die da im Video?
Ah, sich umarmen.
Okay, weil Zalando mehr Geld verdient hat.
Also das Problem ist, in der VM geht ja kein Decoder von der Grafikkarte.
Dementsprechend, guckt es euch mal an, hat es halt ganz schön viel Auslastung, das Video, wenn ich das laufen lasse.
Und umso mehr, umso größer ich den Gramm mache.
Wobei ich sagen muss, das läuft noch halbwegs gut für 1440p.
Das ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Aber es ist halt ein Witz, unter Windows habe ich 3% CPU-Auslastung.
109%, ja, das geht 100% für jeden CPU-Kern.
Der Zimtraucher kommt auf die Hardware an, aber da würde ich mal so mit unterschreiben.
Es gibt ein paar Notebooks, da läuft es ganz gut drauf.
Aber exotischere Sachen eher nicht.
So, also, das funktioniert tatsächlich ganz brauchbar.
CPU-Auslastung ist hoch, aber da kann es nichts dafür.
Das ist einfach, weil es keine Hardware-Decoder hat.
So, kann man hier irgendwelche Sachen customise?
Das zeigt man ja, Desktop-Background.
Was ist denn hier los?
Ich meine, das ist auf der SSD, es sollte jetzt nicht so rumspacken.
Okay, das da brauchen wir um...
Was macht der denn dafür?
Der resized das erste Mal, das ist die Originalgröße und danach wird es resized oder was?
Nee, nee.
What the fuck, was macht der denn da?
Gut, wie dem auch sei, soll mir egal sein, so lange es funktioniert.
Kann man irgendwie das Grün customisern?
Kann man dieses Grün irgendwie customisern, wie kann man Icons ändern?
Administration.
Look.
Appearance.
Das mit dem Schließen-Button, ich weiß nicht, was du mit dem Schließen-Button meinst,
aber was ich vorhin mit dem Schließen-Button meinte, ist, was mir auf den Keks geht, ist,
dass man nicht oben rechts in die Ecke einfach klicken kann und schließen.
Das nervt mich.
Oh, jetzt hat's funktioniert.
Jetzt hat's funktioniert.
Ah, nee.
Funktioniert nicht immer.
Das ist natürlich fail.
Weil das am einfachsten ist, immer oben rechts in die Ecke klicken, ohne zielen zu müssen.
Das ist ja nervig, wenn du auf den Close-Button zielst.
Da frage ich mich immer, wenn Leute sowas entwickeln, benutzen die das selber nicht?
Okay, man kann es ein bisschen ändern, man kann die Sachen blau machen.
Da sieht es ja aus, wie 95R.
Oh.
Mint Dark.
Okay.
Dark Sim ist mir schon mal lieber.
Guck mal, warum springt das immer wieder nach oben?
Das fuckt mich auch schon ab, wenn ich sowas sehe hier.
So.
Nicht wirklich schlimm, aber da denke ich immer so, ey, Alter, benutzt das?
Benutzt das?
Keiner?
Too sharp?
Ja, ist was dran.
Okay, das sieht doch in Blau schon mal ganz brauchbar aus.
Dark Sim, Blau, excellent.
So.
Was konnte man in Appearance noch machen?
Übrigens ist gleich hier unten links, wenn man hier unten links hinklickt, passiert auch nichts.
Es könnte aber auch, mal ganz ehrlich, es könnte auch an der VM liegen.
Ach so, hier Background.
Sind das zwei unterschiedliche Fenster?
Fonts.
Okay, es sind glücklicherweise halbwegs angenehme Sachen eingestellt.
Die Standard Ubuntu Schriftarten sind durchaus okay.
Der Default Mono Space gefällt mir nicht.
Ist irgendwie sowas wie Hack dabei oder Source Code oder irgendwas anderes.
Aber okay, das geht schon das erste Mal.
Das ist ja hübsche Kantenklettung hier.
Ich sehe überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
So, was gibt es bei Interface einzustellen?
Oh, doch so viel, doch so viel.
Dafür lohnt sich ja das Interface Fenster gar nicht.
Show, was?
Show Icons in Menus.
Okay, was passiert, wenn ich das ausmache?
Nix.
Icons sind da.
Icons sind immer noch da.
Oder waren Icons jetzt weg?
Ah, jetzt waren Icons weg, ne?
Aber es sind immer noch Icons da.
Inkonsistent.
Auf jeden Fall recht inkonsistent das Ganze.
Ist Comic Sans dabei?
Okay.
Nein, das ist irgendeine Microsoft Schrift.
Kann man die Schriftart, kann man die Schrift größer machen?
Weil mir ist das ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen klein.
Wow.
Okay, das macht die Schrift nicht größer.
Also, was muss man dann jetzt machen?
Desktop-Font, Document-Font, Application-Font?
Application-Fonte, haben wir 12.
Okay.
Ja, für so Rentner wie mich ist das besser so.
Also, das ist auch schon mal durchaus in Ordnung.
Kannst du kurz Comic Sans nachinstallieren?
Wenn ich wüsste, wie das Paket heißt, ist das MMS-Fonts?
Abinstall MS-Fonts?
Gibt's das?
Comic Neue, gibt's das?
Gibt's das überhaupt?
Fonts Comic.
Less Horrible Remake of Comic Sans.
Ah, yes.
Das brauchen wir.
Allerwichtigste.
Was heißt das so, Sebaro?
Sebaro Massive Brain, wieder am Start.
TTF, MS-Fonts.
Ah, yes.
Ja, natürlich stimmen wir.
Selbstverständlich stimmen wir den Microsoft-Vertragsbedingungen zu.
Was denken die denn überhaupt?
Natürlich.
Ich bin auf die Welt gekommen, schon mit akzeptierter Microsoft-Toss.
So, wir machen jetzt die Konsolen.
So ganz ausgelegt sind die Menüs nicht.
So ganz darauf ausgelegt, auf größere Fonts sind die Menüs wirklich nett.
Linux hat ja immer noch ein bisschen Probleme mit High-DPI-Displays und sowas.
Also da ist noch viel zu tun.
Jetzt, guck mal hier, Areal-Exe wird downgeloaded.
Exquisite.
Hängt jetzt der Installer.
Fonts Unterlin...
Oh.
Lul.
Es geht mittlerweile.
Also ich muss sagen, das Standard Font-Setup-Unterlienungs ist mittlerweile recht gut.
Du brauchst keine custom-gepatchte Freetype mehr und sowas.
Alles okay.
Jetzt hat er es, jetzt ging es.
Jetzt hat er es installiert.
Setz Comic Sans dabei.
Windings ist dabei.
Boah, endlich.
Endlich kann ich mal mein Terminal auf Windings stellen.
Da wart ich schon die ganze Zeit drauf.
Also, auf geht's.
Windings.
Oh, nee, geht das nicht.
Exquisite.
Also, Terminal.
Auf was sagen wir?
MS Comic Sans Regular.
Oh, ja, endlich.
So muss das sein.
Wisst ihr was?
Das ist so ein typischer Terminal-Font, den irgendwelche Lehrer haben an der Schule und
sich wundern, warum die Leute sich darüber lustig machen und sich sagen, wieso, ist doch
normal, ist doch ein ganz netter Font.
Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum ihr das, was ihr da dran habt.
Das typischer Lehrer-Font.
Warum gibt es keinen Windings?
Weil Windings nicht Mono-Space ist.
Aber ist Comic Sans Mono-Space?
Ich meine, es ist Sans.
Es dürfte eigentlich kein Mono-Space sein.
Kann ich denn jetzt hier auf Windings umstellen?
Wind?
Nee, Windings gibt's nicht.
Oder heißt es Wing oder Wind?
Nee, es heißt Windings.
Was?
Webdings?
Ah.
Exquisite.
Webdings.
Ah ja.
Ah, jetzt.
Exquisite Terminal.
So muss das sein.
Ja.
Alles klar.
Sieht fast aus, als habe ich irgendeine Malware installiert.
Das ist doch.
Das ist doch mal was.
Guck mal, der Slash.
Das ist der Windings Slash.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der Windings Slash tatsächlich nach einem Slash aussieht.
Das ist doch mal toll.
So.
Bleib mal zurückstellen.
Äh.
Mono.
So, jetzt können wir da was erkennen.
Okay, hat er keinen sitzlichen Mehrwert gehabt, was wir jetzt ausprobiert haben?
Gut, also customizable ist es zum Teil.
Loop-Freundlichkeit Installer ist okay.
Ich wollte noch gucken, was standardmäßig für Krams mit installiert ist.
Internet, was haben wir dabei?
Äh, Programm zum Linux-Distribution runterladen.
Darf nicht fehlen.
Einen ISC-Chat.
Jetzt, Chat, Chat.
Mal eine ernst gemeinte Frage an euch.
Jetzt sind wir im Linux-Mint-Chat.
Eine ernst gemeinte Frage an euch, Chat.
Hat jemand von euch schon ein ISC verwendet?
Was juckt mich IP-Leak, Alter?
Ja, klar, ne.
Vor circa 15 Jahren.
Ach so, vielleicht sollte ich noch dabei sagen.
In letzter Zeit.
Ich weiß, dass Twitch-Chat IRC unter der Haube IRC hat.
Ja, aber das zählt jetzt nicht.
Keiner connectet sich zum Twitch-Chat mit IRC.
Kaum einer.
Kaum einer ein paar.
Also, IRC ist wirklich nicht mehr 2020 so das Ding.
Das ist auch so was, wo ich nicht so genau verstehe.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, weil IRC nicht wirklich mit der Zeit gegangen ist.
Man darf nämlich nicht vergessen, dass rein für Chat ist IRC wirklich eine super Geschichte.
Und auch mit den Bots, die es früher gegeben hat und den ganzen scriptbaren Sachen,
ist IRC eine richtig coole Geschichte.
Aber die Zeit hat es halt irgendwie überholt.
Und wenn ich mir heute Teams angucke oder Skype oder irgendwelchen anderen Kram,
rein die Chat-Funktion ist IRC immer noch besser.
Und die wurden halt überholt.
Der normale User mag halt, wenn der Client schön ausschaut, was ich auch verstehen kann.
Ich verwende auch lieber einen optisch ansprechenden Client als so ein komisches Ding da in IRC.
QuakeNet.
Ja, QuakeNet war das früher auch jeden Tag.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie die anderen.
Es gab ja noch zwei größere IRC-Server.
Es gab irgendwas mit Freenode oder sowas.
Kann das sein?
Ich habe es vergessen.
Freenode.
Genau, stimmt ja.
Matt schreibt es ja gerade.
Es ist eigentlich ganz nice, aber es hat ziemlich an Bedeutung verloren.
Was haben wir sonst noch dabei?
Internet.
Was sagt ihr?
Exquisite.
Ich spam da jetzt nicht einfach Poggers rein.
Cinnamon, weil Cinnamon in der VM nicht gut läuft.
So, also Internet haben wir hier.
Transmission haben wir dabei.
Das ist, wie gesagt, selbstverständlich nur zum Linus-Distribution runterladen.
Okay, Thunderbird ist dabei.
Der beste schlechte Mail-Client.
Weil ich finde alle anderen noch nerviger.
Thunderbird ist schon okay.
Aber gut finde ich es auch nicht.
Und Firefox ist da am nächsten Teil.
Das ist doch mal ein gutes Setup.
Da kannst du dich nicht großartig drüber beschweren.
Mein Hex-Chat kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, ob man es heutzutage braucht.
Aber der Rest ist in Ordnung.
So, was haben wir dann als nächstes?
Graphics, absoluter Müll hier nur am Start unter Graphics.
Es ist ein ZIP-Programm dabei, ein Taschenrechner.
Übrigens der Gnome-Taschenrechner ist echt auch so ein richtiges Paints-Champ-Tool.
Na ja.
Also, Kerkler, was ist das?
Was?
Irgendein Ding, was ich wahrscheinlich besser nicht verwenden sollte.
Okay, da kann man sich angucken, wie viel frei ist und sonst was drauf.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Warum hat er mir das zweimal positioniert?
Ist das eine für Home und das eine für System oder was macht der da?
Oh nein, nee, der hat mir das gar nicht zweimal positioniert.
Das hier ist das Filesystem und da drauf ist eine Extended Partition oder was ist das?
Was will der mir damit sagen?
Ich hab da nur eine 40G-Platte.
Sitze mal Leute.
Ich weiß nicht, was uns die Ausgabe hier überhaupt sagen soll.
Wir haben SDA5 und SDA2.
Das ist angeblich.
Ach, jetzt kapiere ich das.
Das hier ist die Partition und das hier ist das Filesystem da drauf.
Die machen das von oben nach unten.
Das habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen.
Von unten nach oben.
Okay, von oben nach unten eine komische Anzeige.
Was haben wir sonst noch da drauf?
Schlechtes Notizprogramm.
Noch mal ein extra Image Viewer, der auch nichts taucht.
Ah ja, beste, beste, das brauchen wir.
Redshift.
Auf.
Geht nicht.
Stalken.
Hallo?
Dann wäre es kein zweites Block Device.
Du hast recht.
Ja.
Und jetzt?
Hat es jetzt gestartet oder nicht?
Ja.
Und wie kann ich ihm jetzt sagen, dass er jetzt...
Ah, jetzt ist Nacht.
Äh, ist es jetzt?
Ich sehe da keinen Unterschied dazwischen.
Es kann sein, dass wegen der VM nicht geht.
Du hast recht.
Dann wäre es kein anderes Block Device.
Dev SDA 2 haben wir.
Wir haben SDA 5.
Ah, die Anzeige stimmt schlicht akk...
Nee.
Die Anzeige stimmt schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Ach, das ist eine Extended.
Ach so.
Jetzt habe ich das kapiert.
Das ist eine Extended Partition.
Das ist quasi der Eintrag, dass das eine Extended Partition...
Sowas verwendet man noch?
Ich glaube, ich habe seit 10 Jahren nicht mehr gemacht als maximal 4 Primary Partitions auf der Platte.
Stimmt.
Das gab es ja auch noch.
Ja, nee, Redshift funktioniert wahrscheinlich nicht richtig.
Geht SuperTuxKart.
Oh ja, das Allerwichtigste.
Viel spannender ist, wenn man SuperTuxKart nachinstalliert über die GUI.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das MBR ist.
Wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es bei EFI sowas wie Extended Partitions überhaupt gibt.
Disks.
Doch.
Wahrscheinlich noch.
Doch, doch, doch.
Das ist noch ein FAT.
Das ist noch ein MBT.
MBR, nicht MBT, MBR.
Kennst du Gea Kotz?
Klar.
Also nicht persönlich, aber...
Klar, das ist der Typ mit dem iPhone unter Playstation.
Bei Playstation bin ich mir nicht sicher, aber mit dem iPhone auf jeden Fall.
So, SuperTux...
SuperTuxKart, ja endlich.
Das beste Game aller Zeiten ist am Start.
Aber guck dir mal, also die Usability ist ja mal schon fragwürdig.
Guck mal, die Eigens erkennt doch keine Sau.
Erkennt ihr die Eigens da oben?
Da musst du schon ganz genau hingucken.
Also Darkseam in Ehren.
Aber ich meine, das Weiß im Grün erkennt keiner.
Und das Dunkel in Dunkel erkennt nur wirklich keiner.
Ich denke mir halt, wenn man ein Darkseam hat, was nicht funktioniert,
dann sollte man vielleicht anstatt 5 Darkseams eins machen, was gut funktioniert.
Gab es da nicht so ein fancy Store?
Nö.
Store...
Es gibt dieses Ubuntu Software Center.
Das da meinste, ja.
Stimmt, das gibt es auch noch.
Aber das finde ich ehrlich gesagt ziemlicher Müll, weil es viele Sachen gar nicht findet.
Also wenn du da noch nach VMware-Tools suchst oder...
Oh doch, guck mal, das findet er.
Ah gut, vielleicht stimmt es auch nicht.
Das ist das normale GTK-Standard-Dingstar-Software-Center, was es überall gibt.
Flatpak.
Ja, vielleicht hier drinnen.
So, jetzt kommt ja eh der nächste Punkt.
Oh, Skype.
Please.
Paintschamp.
Ok, gibt es Visual Studio Code?
Yup.
In welcher Version gibt es das?
Das ist aktuell.
Wartet mal kurz.
So, exzellent.
So, 1.5.1 ist glaube aktuell.
Was macht er da eigentlich so eine halbe Stunde rum hier hinten?
Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Ach nee, parallel installieren geht ja nicht, oder?
Was macht er denn jetzt, wenn ich die Sachen parallel installiere?
Ah, das ist jetzt Flatpak.
Wie kann es sein, dass man dauerhaft die Verbindung zum Twitch-Chat verliert?
Also weiß ich nicht.
Also ich verliere die Verbindung nicht.
Ich habe meine Vorschau-Bildschirm offen seit irgendwie zwei Stunden oder so und da ist nichts.
Es kann sein, wenn du das Fenster resized öfters, dass das manchmal rumspackt.
Oder wenn du die Schriftgröße kleiner und größer machst, dann spackt es auch manchmal rum.
Wie ist Code in Flatpak?
Ist einfach nur Mist, sagt Pleuzen.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe noch nie mal Visual Studio Code in Flatpak ausprobiert.
Unofficial, not recommended.
Unofficial-Version.
Ah, alles klar.
This repackaging is not supported by Microsoft.
Ah, weil es Flatpak-Variante ist.
Tja, das würde ich auch mal gerne wissen.
Choose my name.
Warum fangen die jetzt eigentlich mit Flatpak-Gedöns an?
Ich meine, ich finde es schon bescheuert, wie sie auf Ubuntu mit Snap-Geschichten rummachen.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, am liebsten ist es mir, wie sie es unter Manjaro beziehungsweise Artstilungs machen.
Recht gute, supportete Paket-Repo.
Und Millionen...
Guckt es euch an.
Bad Signature.
So fail, Alter.
Kannst du das mal installieren.
Und der Rest aus User-Repos.
Viel besser.
Ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund.
Ich glaube, User-Repos sind der hauptsächliche Grund, warum ich damals bei Arch hängen geblieben bin.
Und?
Geht es jetzt noch mal so lang oder geht es jetzt schneller mit Abkacken?
Vor allem, was macht ihr denn da so ewig?
Man darf nicht vergessen, ich habe dem Ding viel...
Jetzt ging es oder was?
Ist auch sehr unproduktiv irgendwie so die Fehlermeldung.
Flatpak Warning.
Warning.
Ist ja sehr vertrauenserweckend, wenn ich das aufmache und kriege erst mal eine riesenfette Warnung, obwohl ich es aus dem offiziellen Paket-Ding installiert habe.
Okay, das ist Crap.
Das lernt doch kein Mensch.
Ich will den Editor einfach bedienen und nicht irgendwie noch 20 Billionen Sachen lernen dafür.
Fail.
Remove.
Haben die vielleicht irgendeine andere Variante davon, die nicht Flatpak ist?
Und das da zum Beispiel?
Warum gibt es das zweimal?
Flathub, okay.
Das gibt es alles nur als Flatpak, Alter.
Was ist da los?
Warum?
Weil wir sind im Jahr 2020. Package-Manager waren eigentlich einer der großen Vorteile versus Windows, mit denen ich immer geflamet habe.
So und jetzt das allerwichtigste, läuft SuperToxCard.
Was ist Flatpak?
Stell dir es so vor wie ein großes ZIP-Archiv, in dem alles drin ist, was ein Programm braucht, um ausgeführt werden zu können.
Also wenn du dir Gedanken machst, dass beispielsweise der User zig Sachen nicht installiert hat, die du aber brauchst, dass dein Programm läuft, dann packst du alle Abhängigkeiten inklusive deinem Programm in ein ZIP-File und schickst das dem User. So ungefähr ist Flatpak.
So, das wichtigste.
SuperToxCard, jawoll. Endlich geht SuperToxCard.
Beste.
Cat Jam.
Was? Yes.
Offline.
SuperToxCard.
Endlich SuperToxCard.
Oh.
Hallo?
Da habe ich ja drauf gewartet. Jetzt können wir endlich eine Runde SuperToxCard spielen. Nein, wir spielen jetzt kein SuperToxCard.
Aber es läuft gut nach VM.
Sogar mit nicht wirklich großartigem Input-Lag.
Das läuft ziemlich gut.
Es sieht halt, übrigens das Game sieht gar nicht so beschissen aus, wie es hier gerade ist.
Man kann die Graphics noch irgendwie hochballern.
Hallo? Das geht glaube ich nicht im Rennen, ne?
So, Settings.
Graphic Details, Sex, Bam.
Fullscreen.
Äh. Nein.
Ich cancel.
Hallo?
0W. Was macht das?
Monkeys?
Ah.
Das ist geklitscht.
Ok, ok.
So, jetzt machen wir hier mal.
Bam.
Ja.
Exzellent.
So, jetzt passt mal auf. So extrem beschissen sind die Graphics gar nicht.
Wenn halt auch. Wenn halt auch nicht gut, ja.
Ich mein, guckt mal. Es sieht schon mal besser aus als letztes Mal.
Ich mein, wir haben sogar Tiefenschärfe dahinten. Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich mein, es sieht immerhin ähnlich gut aus, wie Mario Kart auf dem 3DS.
Hier. Huge. Huge Graphics. Massive Graphics, wie ihr hier seht.
Es sieht ungefähr aus, wie Mario Kart auf dem 3DS.
Vielleicht doch so wie Mario Kart auf dem DS. Ich weiß nicht.
Super Tuxkart eSport. Easy.
Ob der RTX On ist?
Mario Kart kann einpacken, ja.
Also ich denke auch, Nintendo sollte für die Switch unbedingt mal Super Tuxkart lizenzieren.
Gibt ja eigentlich kaum was geileres als Super Tuxkart auf der Switch.
Stellt euch das mal vor, da könnt ihr das sogar mobil spielen.
Das Problem an Super Tuxkart von der Grafik her ist, es ist halt total inkonsistent.
Manche Sachen sehen brauchbar aus, manche Sachen sehen mega beschissen aus.
Es gibt es auch für Android, ich weiß. Okay, genug Super Tuxkart.
Allerwichtigste Sache geht auch. Es ist Open Source, ja.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen, das stammt aus der Zeit.
Ich glaube, da hat noch keiner was mit Plender gemacht.
Es wird immer noch aktiv entwickelt, aber man könnte mit Sicherheit heutzutage mit Open Source Tools oder zumindest mit kostenlosen Tools viel, viel mehr Besseres erstellen.
Ich meine, Unity kannst du ja auch kostenlos verwenden. Erstmal zumindest.
Also ich meine, da kann ein Super Tuxkart komplett gegenab einpacken. Scheiß dagegen ab.
Irgendeine Mischung aus Plender, Plender und Unity könntest du wahrscheinlich ein richtig gutes Game machen.
Weil wieder Super Tuxkart. Ja, da hast du aber einen guten Moment abgepasst, wenn du das vor Monaten gesehen hast und jetzt wieder.
Ich hab das jeweils zwei Minuten gespielt oder so.
Warum ist Go Dot beste Engine? Warum, warum besser als Unity?
Das musst du mir jetzt erklären, Matt. Ich glaube, man spricht übrigens Go Do aus, nicht Go Dot.
Und das hat mit der Programmiersprache Go glaube ich auch gar nichts zu tun.
Cheese. Excellent.
Mein Gott, die Programme unter Linux sehen echt aus wie hängengeblieben aus 1995.
Was ist das denn?
Auch die Vorschau-Dinger. Soll das sein?
Läuft super cross-platformell gut. Das kann ja Unity auch.
Ich muss also sagen, ich hab weder Ahnung von dem einen noch von dem anderen.
Sieht nach Hello World aus. Tatsächlich hat ein bisschen was von Hello World.
Okay, was wollen wir noch gucken? Wie ist Code Atom? Firefox haben wir. Chrome, ja stimmt.
Was für eine aktuelle Chrome-Version haben wir denn? Oder haben wir eine aktuelle Chrome-Version?
Chrome, Chromium, irgendwas in der Richtung. Chrome, Chrome.
Haben wir einen Google? Google Chrome, direkt selbst drauf.
Ein Android Studio haben wir, okay. Und Google Chromium.
Haben wir einen ordentlichen Chromium drauf. Chromium, ja, okay.
Gibt's denn Chromium mit Hardware-Decoding?
Ich mein, bringt uns nix, weil wir können ihn nicht verwenden.
Warum gibt es eigentlich hier Chrome 50 Schma drinne? Wo ist da der Sinn von?
Versteh ich nicht.
Matt, das ist tatsächlich interessant, weil so richtig viele gute Cross-Platform GUI-Programme,
also Frameworks gibt's ja nicht. Ich mein, du hast Qt, okay.
Aber das Problem ist, das ist C++. Du hast Electron. Electron, ja, Paints-Champ.
Ja, und du hast ein paar halbgare Sachen auf.NET-Basis.
Du hast Flutter, was aber auf dem Desktop noch nicht so richtig gut ist.
Also, ganz im Ernst, rein für GUI kann ich verstehen. Es gibt ja nicht viel.
Okay, Chromium am Start. YouTube. Gucken, ob da wieder die Performance ist,
ob die besser oder schlechter gleich Firefox ist.
Ah ja, ich agree. Free immer, bei allem. Ja, schön für Felix und Alexander.
Nein, YouTube ist so nervig geworden mit diesen Sachen.
Okay, mehr oder weniger ungefähr gleiche Auslastung wie beim Firefox.
Ja, macht keinen Unterschied. Ist aber auch klar, wie gesagt, kein Hardware-Decoder.
Was haben wir sonst zu bieten? Das müssen wir ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Was haben wir für eine Docker-Version? Das finde ich auch ganz interessant.
Na gut, da muss ich nicht gucken. Wir haben die gleich. Das müssen wir nicht ausprobieren.
Das ist die gleiche Docker-Version wie aus dem aktuellen Ubuntu.
Ja, das ist auch docker.io, glaube ich, immer bei.
Nee, das war Ab-, das war, äh, war es nicht Status? War es List?
Was ist Info? Das war Jam-Info war das. Show, Show ist es hier, glaube ich.
Version Nummer 1903. Gucke wie aktuell das ist.
Dürfte Vorletzte sein oder sowas. Oh, also 1903.8.
Was ist Docker-, äh, ein Frontend für Linux-Container? Oh, ist busy.
Steht da normalerweise nicht dran, von wann das rausgekommen ist?
Immer links? Hä? Ach nee, da steht alles noch dabei.
Hä, warum? Warum hängen die das denn untereinander? What the fuck?
Okay, dann müssen wir hier oben mal umstellen.
Vom März. War ein halbes Jahr alt, okay.
Äh, da kannst du dich nicht drauf verlassen, Großartig, wenn hier irgendwo ein Datum dabei steht.
So, okay, das ist ja okay, das ist halbwegs aktuell.
Ähm, gut, nachdem es Ubuntu ist, müssen wir uns den Spaß nicht angucken.
Ist Hardtop standardmäßig drauf? Nee.
Aber das Beste, das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Community, ja die Mid-Community ist relativ groß, das brauche ich auch nicht gucken.
Ja, also ich muss euch sagen, immer noch besser als Ubuntu auf dem Desktop,
du kannst wenigstens Icons auf dem Desktop hin und her schieben und überhaupt,
du kriegst, du kannst beim aktuellen Ubuntu-Desktop keinen Firefox-Icon auf dem Desktop machen,
beziehungsweise, nein, das stimmt nicht, keine Bookmark-Ordner und sowas auf dem Desktop erstellen,
so ganz, ganz merkwürdig. Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, wisst ihr was, jetzt mal,
mein Manjaro mit I3 vorkonfiguriert mal außen vor, weil das ist meine tägliche Sache, die ich verwende,
aber wisst ihr was mir bisher von allen Linux-Dingern, die wir ausprobiert haben, am besten gefallen hat?
Wir haben ja schon viel, wir haben ja schon echt vieles durch, ja.
Mint ist jetzt das zweite Mal, das wir uns angucken, wir haben uns Elementary angeguckt,
wir haben uns das China Linux angeguckt, wir haben uns zig andere kleine Sachen angeguckt
und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, so doof es klingt, das China Linux war vom Gesamtpaket hier bisher echt das Beste.
Nicht Gentoo, das hier.
Das da.
PopOS haben wir uns auch angeguckt, ja. Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, rein vom Eindruck her,
was es auf mich gemacht hat nach dem Installieren, wie customizable es ist, wie gut alles zusammenpasst,
war mir das bisher von allen Sachen, die wir ausprobiert haben, am liebsten.
Rein als Linux-Noob, der von Windows umsteigen würde, Sicht, hat mir am besten gefallen.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute würden damit auch am besten klarkommen.
Ich meine, ich bleibe bei meinem Manjaro mit I3, das ist klar, aber
glaub, mit Deepin würden die meisten Leute am glücklichsten.
Es ist halt nur die Frage, ob man sich in China Linux installieren will.
Don't Cry So Much sagt, überlege gerade von Windows auf Linux zu wechseln, weil ich ein ordentliches Terminal will.
Sieht da bis jetzt nicht ganz so schön aus.
Ja, das ist das Problem an Linux auf dem Desktop.
Linux auf dem Desktop hat die gleichen Probleme wie Nextcloud.
90% ist gut und tut, aber das Polish fehlt einfach.
Und du kannst ja viele der der bekannten guten Sachen auch unter Windows verwenden.
Und mit Windows, mit WSL, mit dem neuen WSL ist es ja auch ganz brauchbar unter Windows.
Eine der Sachen, die halt nicht gut funktioniert unter Windows mit WSL sind grafische Programme, falls man doch mal was braucht.
Ja, kann man verwenden, aber ich schwör da auf mein Manjaro mit I3, beste.
Aber das ist jetzt nichts, was ich verwenden würde direkt zum Einsteigen.
Wobei, warum eigentlich nicht mal ganz im Ernst?
Ich sag immer, ich sag immer, I3 würde ich nicht zum Einstieg empfehlen.
Aber ganz im Ernst, warum eigentlich nicht?
Ich mein, was ist da groß dabei, I3 als Einstieg?
Ich mein, du musst dir merken, mit 1, 2, 3 wechselt man die Desktops.
Bei mir ist es mit Ctrl D, Status der Anwendung.
Und Zwischenablage hast du bei mir mit Ctrl P.
So, fertig. Mehr musst du dir doch eigentlich gar nicht merken.
Man muss sich da nur ein bisschen dran gewöhnen, ja.
Gut, die größte Umstellung von einem normalen Windows Desktop auf I3 ist halt,
dass I3 erst mal tiling basiert ist.
Also sprich, du machst ein Terminal auf, es startet im Fullscreen.
Du machst einen Browser auf, der Fullscreen tilt sich.
Du machst noch ein Terminal auf, es trittelt sich.
Du schiebst runter, es ist anders getrittelt, ja.
Also, das ist, glaube ich, so die größte Gewöhnung, was I3 angeht.
Allerdings kann man bei I3 ja auch einfach Shortcut drücken,
dann hat man wieder Windows-Windows am Start, wenn man das haben will.
Also, wenn man wirklich Fenster möchte und rumschieben will, ja.
Dann kann man das machen.
Warum empfehle ich nicht eigentlich noch mehr Noobs mal I3 auszuprobieren?
Weil es hat ja auch einen Grund letztendlich irgendwie,
weil ich da drauf hängen geblieben bin.
Ich bin da drauf hängen geblieben, weil es mir mit Abstand am besten gefällt
und am am besten gefällt.
Und ich bin da drauf hängen geblieben, weil es mir mit Abstand am besten gefällt
und am angenehmsten im Umgang ist.
Warum sollte das bei anderen nicht auch so sein?
Man fühlt sich lost.
Jaja, das stimmt schon.
Man kommt halt mit Windows-Gedanken in I3 gar nicht weiter.
Aber ansonsten, wie gesagt, du musst ja eigentlich nur merken,
Desktop schalten, Windows-Taste 1, 2, 3, 4.
Okay, Terminal starten, Control-Enter, ja.
Programme starten, Windows-Enter, Programme starten, Windows-D.
Das war es ja eigentlich erst mal. Mehr braucht man da gar nicht großartig.
Ich glaube, ich sollte mehr Noobs I3 empfehlen.
I3 ist wirklich nice.
Ich kann mir das gar nicht mal anders vorstellen, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich keinen Bock habe, auf Windows umzusteigen.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit legen sie einem das ja immer mal nahe,
so nach dem Motto, ja, verwende Windows, dann kümmern wir uns um die Updates
und du musst überhaupt nichts mehr machen.
Es ist auch besser supported.
Du kannst auch an jedes Surface-Hub dran, es funktioniert.
Du kannst unsere Beamer, unsere Präsentationszeug verwenden.
Und ich sag halt auf der Arbeit immer, ne, Alter, geh mal fort mit Windows,
weil ich einfach so sehr an I3 hänge auch
und ich mit I3 schlicht und ergreifend am angenehmsten arbeiten kann.
Das mache ich auch oft.
Wie oft habe ich schon hier drei gedrückt,
weil ich auf meinen Desktop wechseln wollte, ja.
Wie läuft I3 mit mehreren Monitoren?
Wunderbar, kein Problem.
Ich habe auf der Arbeit auch zwei Monitore.
Ich habe so einen ultra-wide 4K und mein Notebook und funktioniert ohne Probleme.
Der I3 ist schon nice.
Der Stubenhocker, das stimmt schon,
aber man braucht erst mal gar nicht so viele Einrichtungsvideos,
weil die Standard-I3-Settings gar nicht so fail sind.
Ich habe ja kaum was geändert.
Also bei...
Taste Enter Terminal ist Default.
Fenster hin und her schieben ist auch Default.
Ich habe kaum was umgestellt an den Default Keybindings.
Ja, Sway geht auch.
Allerdings Wayland wird, ich sag's schon, wird und ist,
also ist aktuell noch und wird es auch bleiben, eine übelste Rockgrippierer.
Bin ich schon überzeugt.
Wenn die es nicht schaffen...
Ich meine, wie lange gibt es den Kram jetzt auch schon?
Zehn Jahre oder so?
Und die haben es nicht geschafft, nennenswerte Verbreitungen so wirklich zu finden
und dass Basic-Sachen funktionieren.
Die hatten Probleme mit V-Sync noch vor zwei Versionen und solche Sachen.
Es gibt richtig schöne, lange Listen, was Probleme an Wayland gibt.
Und ich bin immer denke...
Das ist für Linux im Desktop-Betrieb auch nicht gerade förderlich,
weil die Sache ist halt die, X ist ein olles Ding, ein sau-altes Ding.
Also X ist das hier, worauf der Desktop läuft letztendlich,
auf was der Window-Manager läuft, also das, was die grafische Ausgaben macht.
X ist uralt, übelst kompliziert,
keine Sau blickt mehr durch, keiner will mehr was dran machen.
Im Prinzip unterm Strich voll von Arsch.
Wayland hat ambitioniert gestartet,
krebs seit zehn Jahren rum,
Basic-Sachen wie Resize und wie es irgendwie nicht richtig funktionieren.
Ja, wie sieht denn da die Alternative aus?
Noch die nächsten 40 Jahre X verwenden?
Oder aber es kommt mal wieder irgendwie irgendein Ubuntu-Typ
oder irgendein anderer Typ auf die Idee und sagt,
Alter, leckt mich, ich baue jetzt was Eigenes,
mit ein bisschen Geld dahinter und ein paar Entwicklern dahinter
und dann kommt dann halt irgendwas.
Erfahrungen mit Android? Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Erfahrungen mit Android.
Ich habe Android mal installiert vor längerer Zeit
und habe festgestellt, dass das nicht so mein System ist.
Und dann habe ich mir gesagt,
ja, ich habe Android mal installiert vor längerer Zeit
und habe festgestellt, dass das nicht so mein System ist.
Serious Max, damit kann man kein Geld machen.
Und was geht's?
Ich habe mich gerade ein bisschen über X und Wayland ausgekotzt.
Matt, kann ich nicht beurteilen, ob das so ist?
Naja, man sieht es an vielen Stellen,
dass die halt dadurch auch ziemlich den Anschluss verlieren.
Hi DPI unter Linux ist auch so ein bisschen fragwürdig,
ob das gut funktioniert, also meistens eher nicht.
Und ansonsten, du hast halt bei Linux auf dem Desktop das große Problem,
wie gesagt, das gleiche Problem, was auch Nextcloud und solche Sachen haben.
Das ist nicht schlecht, aber der Polish fehlt einfach an vielen Stellen.
Guckt euch den Image Viewer von Mint an, das ist ja absolute Zumutung, das Ding.
Ja, der Zimtraucher, das kommt noch dazu,
dass viele Sachen in Linux auch übelst wir sind von der Benamung her.
Es kommt dazu, dass viele Sachen inkonsistent sind.
Aber gut, ich meine, das ist unter Windows nicht wirklich besser.
Die Sache ist nur die, wenn Leute dann versuchen umzusteigen
und mit diesen Windows, mit den verwirrenden Sachen aus der Windows Welt
dann zu den verwirrenden Sachen in die Linux Welt gehen,
dann sind sie halt ganz schnell frustriert.
Deswegen, was ich Noobs, die umsteigen wollen, immer sage ist,
man soll gar nicht mit dem Gedanken dran gehen,
dass es sich wie Windows bedienen lässt.
Es mag zwar auf den ersten Blick Ähnlichkeiten haben,
zum Beispiel Mint, dass du eine Taskleiste hast, was starten kannst,
aber sobald du auch nur einen Hauch von mehr machen willst,
als du im ersten Menü klicken kannst, musst du dein Terminal aufmachen und halt ran.
Das ist nicht schlimm, als jemand, der Linux seit Jahren verwendet,
hat man sich daran gewöhnt und ich mache Sachen lieber im Terminal
und ich konfiguriere Sachen lieber im Terminal, als über irgendeine GUI geklicke.
Aber das verwirrt halt erstmal, das schreckt ganz viele Leute ab.
Und warum ist das so?
Weil, und das ist eine Sache, das kann man Microsoft echt angreifen,
dass Windows Terminal und die Windows Shell abgrund tiefer Scheiß sind.
Mittlerweile gibt es ein neues Terminal und PowerShell ist zumindest für Scripting ganz brauchbar.
PowerShell ist als interaktive Shell halt nicht zu gebrauchen,
aber Automatisierung über PowerShell ist okay,
aber wenn man sich mal ehrlich anguckt,
vergleicht mal so einen Terminal hier mit diesem Ding da.
Das ist halt der Witz.
Windows Terminal und Batch, das ist echt das Schlimmste, was es gibt.
Deswegen sind auch so viele Anwender davon abgeschreckt.
Die sagen, oh nein, da muss man in dem Terminal was eingeben, oh nein, ein Terminal.
Da denkst du, die Leute müssen sterben, Alter.
In Wirklichkeit ist es so, Sachen, die ordentlich im Terminal umgesetzt sind,
funktionieren in der Regel besser, als wenn du 100.000 GUI Fenster dafür hast.
Aber die Leute sind so allergisch gegen das Terminal, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Die meisten Leute hassen Terminal wie die Pest, weil sie nur das Windows Terminal kennen.
Das ändert sich gerade, das ändert sich erst dann,
wenn das vorinstalliert ist und wenn eine gescheite Shell dabei ist.
Die PowerShell ist gut.
Also die PowerShell ist schon nicht schlecht.
Die PowerShell sackt halt als interaktive Shell.
Also zum täglich arbeiten und Sachen machen ist PowerShell nicht so geil,
meiner Ansicht nach.
Die automatisierte Scriptingsachen ist PowerShell cool.
Einer der Unterschiede zwischen zum Beispiel hier so einer Bash
oder eine ZSH, weiß gar nicht, was das ist, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, das ist eine Bash.
Ist das Bash alles Text ist und in PowerShell sind das echte.NET Objekte.
Und für Automatisierung Sachen echt cool.
Ja, das JUP und deswegen ist das Unterlinus ganz nice.
Du kannst ja prinzipiell eh nur bei dir was kaputt machen, im System nichts.
Du hast halt auch viele Hilfen dabei.
Du hast bei den meisten Sachen mittlerweile halbwegs brauchbare Autocompletion dabei und sowas.
Wenn man sich da ein bisschen mit auseinandersetzt, ist das über das Terminal zu machen vieles
deutlich angenehmer als in 30 Optionsmenüs rumzuklicken.
Aber Windows User haben da halt so eine richtig harte Abneigung dagegen.
Verständlicherweise.
Also das letzte Mal, wo ich PowerShell verwendet habe, ich gebe zu, das ist schon ein bisschen her,
war das für tägliche interaktive Sachen kacke.
Also wenn du natürlich Server Automatisierung machst oder sowas mit PowerShell, kann ich verstehen, dass das geil ist.
Aber als tägliche interaktive PowerShell, weiß ich, da bin ich dich mit warm geworden.
Aber ich meine, die Geschmäcker sind ja letztendlich verschieden.
Ist ja gut, wenn das bei dir funktioniert.
Mir hat das nicht gefallen.
Das ist ziemlich erschrott.
Hast du mal dem Small Linux gearbeitet?
Ich habe das mal ausprobiert, ja.
Ich hatte aber noch keinen Anwendungszweck für.
Fisch habe ich auch vor Jahren mal ausprobiert, aber nie mit warm geworden.
Hast du schon mal Paypalast ausprobiert?
War das ein Game?
Nee, das war Papers Please.
Was ist das?
Ach, das ist der Scanner, dieses OCR Ding, oder?
Nee, habe ich schon nicht ausprobiert.
Doch, das liegt am Windows Terminal.
Das liegt auf jeden Fall mit am Windows Terminal.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es nur am Windows Terminal liegt.
Es liegt daran, dass dieses Ding schon so oldschool aussieht wie aus 1960.
Beschissen vorkonfiguriert ist.
Keiner einer Hilfe, kryptischer Kack zum Eingeben.
Dass sich da keiner dran traut, ist klar.
Muss ich nicht beim Terminal die ganzen Befehle auswendig können?
Wirklich? Du brauchst ein paar Standard-Dinger.
Aber das würde ich ähnlich vergleichen.
Du kennst doch auch deine 5-6 Programme, die du täglich verwendest.
Du weißt, dass du zum E-Mails lesen Outlook brauchst.
Du weißt, dass du zum Internet angucken Firefox oder Chrome brauchst.
Wenn du krass einen MOBA-Bash machen willst, musst du ganze LoL starten.
Du brauchst einen Explorer, um Dateien zu suchen.
Das ist ja ähnlich.
Du kommst im Terminal mit 20 Kommandos ganz gut aus.
Manpages liest ja eh keiner.
Ich lese auch keine Manpages. Ich Google immer danach.
Viele Manpages sind nicht zum Lesen geschrieben, sondern um Leute zu verwirren.
Meine Lieblingsmanpage, um Leute zu verwirren.
Beziehungsweise haben wir Git installiert.
Um zu zeigen, dass Manpages nicht zum Lesen gemacht sind, sind wir das hier.
Auf, installier. Let's go.
Lest euch mal die ersten paar Sätze durch.
Versteht da wirklich irgendjemand, was das macht?
Versteht keiner.
Git push.
Alles klar.
Dabei ist Git push eines der am häufigsten nutzenden Befehle überhaupt.
Das ist immer mein Lieblingsbeispiel für, dass Manpages oftmals nicht zum Lesen geschrieben sind.
Und das nächste schafft auch sehr viel Vertrauen.
You can make interesting things happen every time you push into it.
Bei Setting, da kommen sie noch mit Hooks an.
Alter, wer sich gedacht hat, das ist eine gute Idee.
Übrigens, selbst wenn man sich auskennt, macht das zwar ein bisschen Sinn, aber eine gute Erklärung für push ist es nicht.
Das ist immer mein Lieblingsbeispiel für, wenn einer sagt Manpages.
Warum benutzt man Programme für Mails? Ich nutze dafür Gmail auf Manpages.
Kannste machen, wenn du das nur auf dem Handy liest.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel Thunderbird schon eine ganze Weile, also seit Jahren am Start.
Da habe ich fünf Mailboxen drin.
Auch noch eine uralt GMX Gmail. Ich habe sogar noch eine uralt web.de und so ein Geschiss am Start.
Mit ein paar Filtern drin.
Das schöne ist, dass ich meine Historie habe in Thunderbird Mails der letzten 15 Jahre quasi.
Ja, aber ganz ehrlich, wenn man nur eine E-Mail Adresse hat und die bei Google ist und man da nicht lokale Backups haben will,
warum nicht? Dann kann man auch einfach Gmail im Browser verwenden, spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen.
TLDR, das habe ich glaube ich schon mal ausprobiert.
Das ist genau so wie TheFuck. Kennt ihr TheFuck auf GitHub?
TheFuck. TheFuck.
Ja.
Wenn du dich verschrieben hast, so funktioniert das.
Du hast dich verschrieben und dann gibst du ein Fuck und der korrigiert das für dich.
Vielleicht etwas für dich, genau das kenne ich schon.
Du hast dich verschrieben und gesagt Fuck und der korrigiert es für dich.
Eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Wusstet ihr, dass Git sowas eingebaut hat?
Man kann bei Git eine Autokorrektur einbauen. Ich glaube, das heißt Git re re re war das glaube ich.
Ach nee, re re re ist für Merch-Konflikte. Wie hieß das unter Git nochmal?
Git autocorrekt. Wie hieß das Ding nochmal?
Da bekommt man dann so einen Timeout. Ja genau. Das heißt sogar autocorrekt.
Da bekommt man einen Timeout, der sagt, du hast außerdem Git lgo eingegeben.
Und der hat gefragt nach 1,5 Sekunden führe ich automatisch log aus.
Also die haben sowas sogar schon eingebaut.
Aber TheFuck beste.
So TLDR Git.
Das habe ich noch nicht verwendet.
Was mache ich jetzt? Git push? Wie rufe ich das jetzt auf?
Wusstet ihr, dass Git eine GUI eingebaut hat? Du meinst diese Craft-Geschichte, die ASCII malt?
TLDR Git kommt ja nichts.
Ach das ist alles oder was?
Damit kommt man jetzt nicht wirklich weiter, oder?
Git push gibt es keine extra Manpage für.
So durfte es zu verwenden.
Ja gut, aber das bringt jetzt auch nicht wirklich großartig was, oder?
Was Git GUI?
Gibt es nicht?
Git Command.
Ja, aber wisst ihr mal ganz davon abgesehen, was das einfachste ist?
Mein Git push in...
Wisst ihr was das einfachste ist? Wenn ihr wissen wollt, wie man Commando bedient.
Das ist das beste.
Ohne Scheiß.
Egal, Manpages, TLDR, alles umsonst, einfach Google aufmachen, Stack Overflow und gut ist.
Probier es mal auf Manjaro, kann ich machen.
Ja Windows, ja wahrscheinlich, weil sie da irgendwie was für die Windows-NOOBS eingebaut haben.
Ok, gucken wir mal auf Manjaro.
TLDR, Git.
Sieht immer noch genauso aus.
Wenn Stack Overflow down ist, sind alle lost, ja das stimmt.
Push.
Ah, das ist doch schon besser.
Ok, das ist ok.
Git GUI.
Wish not found.
Wish.
Wollt ihr mir mal einen Rasierer bestellen oder so?
Was zum Teufel ist Wish?
Wo ist überhaupt installiert, um Wish zu bekommen?
Kenn ich nicht.
Wusste ich nicht, dass das eingebaut ist.
Ok, was muss ich installieren für Wish?
Ok, Wish not found.
Ach, das ist bestimmt so ein Bash-Kram.
Nee.
Wish not found, was muss ich installieren?
Zeig her.
TK, TOI, Git, das ist ein TK-Programm.
Ach du große Scheiße.
Ok, es wird hässlich aussehen.
Es wird auf jeden Fall hässlich aussehen.
Pains Champ.
Git K kenne ich, das benutze ich sogar ab und zu mal.
Ok.
Ok, ich gebe zu, man kann das durchaus als GUI bezeichnen.
Wie sinnvoll das ist, sei mal dahingestellt.
Gut, ich mache das mal wieder zu.
Ich will das gar nicht so genau wissen.
Jetzt remove ich diesen Kram mal wieder.
So sieht das auch bei Windows aus.
Ja, das ist ja der schöne an TK, das funktioniert cross-platform halbwegs.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, es gibt kaum gute cross-platform GUI-Frameworks.
Es sieht wirklich aus, wie Git GUI auf Wish bestellt.
Ja, genau so sieht es aus.
Genau so sieht es aus.
Wenn ich Git GUI auf Wish bestelle, dann sieht es so aus.
Ja, ich schwöre ja auf Git Kommando Zeile.
Also ich kann mit Git GUI überhaupt nichts anfangen.
Der Vorteil von der Git Kommando Zeile ist, man weiß genau, was passiert.
Was bei GUI nicht so ist.
Wir hatten mal einen Entwickler, der hat Eclipse verwendet.
Eclipse mit E-Git.
Also E-Git, aber man spricht das E-Git, was eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Aussprache ist für so ein Tool.
Und der hat teilweise irgendwelche leeren Comets gehabt.
Weil er dann irgendwie versucht hat zu cherrypicken über die GUI und so.
Ganz komisches Zeug.
Aber ganz im Ernst, man muss sich mit Git gar nicht großartig beschäftigen.
Man braucht so, keine Ahnung, so 6, 7 Commands vielleicht.
Damit kommt man erstmal gut aus.
Ich meine, du musst dir die, du musst die History angucken.
Du musst Status machen.
Du musst mal pushen, mal pullen, mal ein Remote Update machen.
Ja.
Matt, ich auch, ich auch.
Wir haben bei uns Kandidaten drin, die teilweise, alter, was die bei uns teilweise für Dinge einchecken, ist echter Wahnsinn.
Du hast dann Leute, die haben dann irgendwie vor 5 Jahren mal rebased oder so.
Und zwischendurch dann irgendwie andere Sachen noch reingemerged von einem anderen Kollege, der aber auch schon 3 Monate alt ist.
Alter, da werden teilweise Merchrequests aufgemacht mit irgendwie 400 Comets.
Weil er nicht richtig rebased hat und Git denkt, die History passt nicht mehr zusammen und sowas.
Also manche Leute, und wisst ihr was das Schlimme ist?
Die, die es verkacken sind, sind zum größten Teil irgendwelche externen Konsultants, wo man sich fragt, wo wir wieder bei meinem alten Lieblingsthema sind,
wo man sich fragt, für was soll man diese ganzen Konsultanten eigentlich alles konsulten?
Was verwendet ihr auf der Arbeit? GitLab? Nee, Bitbucket.
PaintsChamp Bitbucket.
Wir hatten einen GitLab, das hatte ich damals installiert.
Also ein handinstallierter Server von Max war das damals, ja.
Und das wurde dann aber zwangsabgelöst durch Bitbucket,
weil Bitbucket quasi unternehmensweit Standard werden sollte.
Das war den Stonksleuten ganz wichtig.
Einfach Force pushen, ja das bringt dir nichts Force pushen in dem Fall,
weil du machst ja eine Merchrequest auf und wenn der Merchrequest auf dem Master 400 Comets beinhaltet,
weil du nicht richtig Rebase hast, da bringt dir Force pushen nichts, weil ich Merch'n nicht.
Da hatte ich schon Diskussionen.
Die meisten sehen das ein und die meisten verkacken es vielleicht 1-2 Mal und verstehen dann, was sie machen müssen.
Aber wir haben beispielsweise einen Kandidat auf der Arbeit,
der ist jetzt aber auch glaube ich Ende des Jahres dann weg, hat sich auskonsultet.
Der hat es jetzt seit 2 Jahren, bekommt er das nicht hin, ordentliche Comets zu machen.
Oh ja Main, Main sorry.
Ja auf der Arbeit heißen unsere Branchen immer noch Master.
Und wisst ihr was?
Die bleiben auch so.
Ich habe da keinen Bock, nur wegen irgendwelchen Vorstellungen mancher Leute im Kopf,
dass das was Schlimmes wäre, da mir eine große Arbeit zu machen, die Sachen umzustellen.
Habe ich einfach keinen Bock drauf.
Wenn mir da irgendwie einer einen sinnvollen technischen Grund für sagen könnte, warum das besser ist, okay.
Aber einfach nur, weil sich manche Leute dann besser fühlen, muss ich das nicht machen.
Ihr seid aber böse Kenpachi.
Ja Black und White Lists.
Die Abmahnung aber schon sicher.
Ne Default ist glaube ich immer noch Master.
Und ich glaube Default wird auch weiterhin Master bleiben.
Aber man hat jetzt die Option, das umzustellen.
Also eins muss man ja sagen, der gute Linus, also nicht der YouTube Linus, der Git und Linux Linus,
der hat ja so einen Selbstfindungspause gemacht vor einer Zeit,
wo er gesagt hat, er macht mal ein bisschen Pause und denkt irgendwie über sein Leben nach oder so
und will sich ein bisschen beruhigen, dass er nicht mehr so viel ausrastet.
Und seitdem ist er auch, ist er wirklich deutlich umgänglicher geworden überall, wenn man so rumguckt.
Früher hat Linus ja gerne übels rumgerantet an jeder Ecke, hat er mal ein bisschen rumgerantet.
Also hätte einer einen Merchrequest aufgemacht, oder ich weiß gar nicht, als was da reingekommen ist,
Feature Request, wahrscheinlich in irgendeiner Mailing Liste, Master zu Main umzubenennen,
also quasi Pre-Reformed Linus, der hätte rumgeflamed as fuck.
Aber jetzt, nachdem er quasi Selbstfindungsphase dahinter sich hatte, er ist reformed,
jetzt hat er nicht rumgeflamed.
Er hat sich ein Rentfilter eingebaut, ja.
Wissen deine Kollegen eigentlich, dass du streamst, ein paar wissen das, ja, aber die meisten nicht,
die meisten wollen es wahrscheinlich auch nicht wissen und ich erzähle sie noch nicht.
Tja, Reboot mal kurz.
Oh, huge Bildschirmschoner.
Wisst ihr was?
Jetzt mal ehrlich, sogar der Bildschirmschoner sieht pothässlich aus,
also der Unlock, der Unlock-Screen sieht pothässlich aus.
Das gibt's bei Apple nicht so was.
Oh, zwei Zeichen gespart, das stimmt.
Aber du nimmst damit in Kauf, dass erst mal keiner weiß wovon du redest
und dass vielleicht manche Sachen, die folgmäßig nicht nach Main gucken.
Wie oft nutzt du CACW auf der Arbeit, mehr als sinnvoll ist.
Ich habe auch schon Comets gemacht, wo CACW drin stand.
Allerdings heute habe ich mir gedacht,
bei meinem letzten Comet heute habe ich mir gedacht,
die Sachen, die ich da eingecheckt habe, sind eher MonkaS.
MonkaS im MonacS-Projekt.
Haben eure Comets eigentlich Signaturen?
Ah, nee, haben sie nicht.
Das ist über die Vorder, die Leute wahrscheinlich wieder.
Nee, nee, habe ich schon mal drüber nachgedacht.
Wäre eigentlich eine coole Sache, weil du könntest wirklich sicher nachvollziehen,
wer was macht, wer was macht.
Wobei man das auch so kann.
Ich glaube nicht, dass bei uns einer wirklich absichtlich was faked.
Aber es wäre zum Beispiel ganz praktisch, um sicher zu gehen,
dass auch keiner irgendwelche Comets macht, die er nicht machen darf.
Also zum Beispiel sollte mal wirklich irgendwie ein Notebook gehackt werden
oder ein Notebook irgendwie verloren gehen.
Oder irgendwas merkwürdiges.
Wenn natürlich der Private Key da drauf ist, dann hast du auch verloren.
Dann wäre das noch was, ja.
Wäre ganz cool.
Aber ich glaube, das wird wieder so viele Leute verwirren.
Wenn ich mir schon angucke, wie viele Leute von so einem Basics Git Workflows verwirrt sind.
In Form von ab und zu mal rebasen.
Dann mal ein ordentliches Comet machen, vielleicht mal ein paar Comets zusammenfassen.
Nichts Großes, ja.
Wenn ich sehe, wie viele Leute davon schon immer hoffnungslos überfordert und verwirrt sind.
Ich sag besonders unser einer Konsultant, der Ende des Jahres weg ist.
Nee, da kannst du das knicken.
Point 3, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Nee, ja, mag sein.
Aber ich meine damit immer nur die Paints-Champel-Leute, die mir auf den Keks gehen.
Mit den meisten verstehe ich mich gut.
Und über die würde ich auch nichts schlechtes sagen.
Aber über wenige halt gerne ein bisschen ablästere sind zum Beispiel Leute,
die Konsultant sind, dicke fette Kohle verdienen und die Basics in Sachen nicht hinbekommen.
Das regt mich auf.
Und da haben wir mindestens zwei Stück gerade von.
Einer extrem, der andere nicht ganz so.
Ja und sagen wir so firmenweit haben wir da viel zu viele von.
Wir haben so viele unglaublich viele Konsultants, wo ich mich frage, wofür sind die überhaupt da?
Echt Wahnsinn.
Ja und die meisten Leute, über die ich läste, sind nicht meine Kollegen, sondern irgendwelche anderen Leuten von der Arbeit.
Also nicht meine direkten Kollegen.
Und da haben wir halt auch leider sehr viele Paints-Champel-Leute.
Ich sag nur das System geht nicht.
Ja um welches System handelt es sich denn?
Na das System, mit dem wir täglich arbeiten.
Solche Leute haben wir da für jede Menge.
Schon mal Xmonad verwendet.
Nein, es gibt hier ganz viele Subs.
Was ist denn hier los?
Train94, Dankeschön für den Sub Stufe 1.
Und der Flamongo auch.
Vier Monad, Dankeschön für die Subscriptions.
Vier mal Prime.
Dankeschön, nice.
Wenn die Konsultants auch konsultet, ja mit Sicherheit werden die konsultet, nämlich von ihrem jeweiligen Personalmensch, der ja will, dass sie möglichst lange für uns konsulten.
Konsultants, der Surf Jelly sagt, Konsultants sind eh leider meist nur PP, gar welche Powerpoint machen.
Ja, aber uns nicht.
Also wir haben auch wirklich ein paar, nennen wir es mal extern eingekaufte, in Anführungsstrichen Experten, die echt viel Kohle kassieren, für das, dass sie fachlich eigentlich was können sollten.
Da ist halt bei einigen echt nichts zu holen, ich weiß gar nicht, was die machen.
CLI Jumper, zwei Monate, danke für die Subs.
Was ist jetzt los auf einmal?
Das Scam Train ist ja sogar am Start.
Das Scam Train fährt ab, Leute.
Gebate zum Subscriben.
Können die wenigstens SSH oder Git?
Wie gesagt, also wir haben einen ganz besonders tollen Experten, der tut sich seit zwei Jahren, der ist seit zwei Jahren nicht in der Lage, Git so weit zu bedienen, dass ich nicht Zustände bekomme bei jedem Merchrequest.
So.
Und SSH kann der bedienen, ja.
Aber bei advanceden Sachen wie SSH Tunnel hört es schon wieder auf.
Und das ist auch, der Typ ist eh geil.
Der fragt dich irgendwas.
Keine Ahnung, er sagt mir hier, wie kann ich, oder fragt, er fragt mich irgendwie, ja okay, ich muss was von da nach da kopieren, aber Firewall mäßig geht nicht.
Dann sag ich, boah, lass mal überlegen, hast du schon mal im SSH Tunnel probiert?
So und anstatt, dass der dann sagt, ah, gute Idee, danke für den Hinweis, ich guck mir das mal an, so allein schon ein Witz, dass er es nicht weiß, ja.
Ist der dann so frech und sagt noch, ja, wo ist das dokumentiert?
Alter, schmeißt Google an und guckt.
Und guck, ey.
Boah, das triggert, der Typ triggert mich extrem immer.
Jetzt seh ich schon, der Chat, der Chat kennt auch so Leute.
Ey, das, ohne Scheiß, Leute, das, das, das, das, so, ohne Spaß, wisst ihr, wie ist der Assi Tony gesagt?
Nee, aber das, das triggert mich jedes Mal, ey.
Jede Teamrunde regt das mich auf.
Weil jede Teamrunde ist irgendwas in dieser Richtung.
Dann sagt einer, was? Und dann heißt dann, ja, hier, Herr Super Experte, was sagen Sie dazu?
Dann sagt er, ja, was soll ich dazu sagen?
Da müsste man mal gucken, wo ist das denn dokumentiert?
Alter, da krieg ich Anfälle, ey.
Das wäre mir als Consultant zu peinlich, ehrlich gesagt.
Naja, okay, ach so, das Wichtigste, gibt's das ASCII-Quarium hier überhaupt, oder?
Mensch, das Allerwichtigste.
Was? Nein, gibt's nicht?
Oh, fail.
Ohne ASCII-Quarium geht da wirklich gar nichts.
Punkt Default, danke schön für den Subscription.
Wie ist das eigentlich bei euch mit Azubis?
Bin zurzeit selber einer und frag mich, ob mein Ausbilder manchmal denkt,
was ist denn das für ein PP-Ger?
Nö, bei Azubis denke ich das nicht.
Außer, es ist der Spezial Azubi.
Der nach Wochen üben sich nichts davon merkt.
Das ist eine Ausnahme gewesen.
Aber über Azubis rede ich mich nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich freue mich, wenn wir denn, in letzter Zeit haben wir relativ wenige bei uns,
ich freue mich über jeden Azubi, der sinnvolle Sachen fragt.
Oder der zu einem kommt und fragt hier, ich hab keinen Plan davon, wie das geht, kannst du mir mal zeigen?
Und so, das finde ich gut.
Ich freue mich da über jeden Azubi, der sich für die Sache interessiert.
Weil letztendlich, irgendwoher müssen die Leute es ja lernen.
Ich erwarte von keinem Azubi, dass der irgendwas kann.
Aber wenn ich mit einem Azubi wochenlang mir was angucke, dann erwarte ich zumindest,
dass er sich ein bisschen was gemerkt hat.
Das Jupp.
Ja, gut. Gibt Leute, verstehe ich.
Aber man sollte nicht bei der gleichen Sache fünfmal fragen, oder?
Also irgendwann ist ja auch mal gut.
Vor allem nicht, wohlgemerkt, wenn das eigentlich zu deinen Basisaufgaben gehören sollte, als sowas zu wissen.
Ich rede ja hier nicht von irgendwelchen komplizierten Sachen,
sondern von Standard-Administrationen, also von absoluten Standard-Administrationstools.
Also wenn heute einer keine Git-Basics kann, das ist ungefähr so,
wie wenn ein Arzt nicht weiß, wie er ein Stethoskop benutzt.
Oder wie ein Schreiner nicht weiß, wie er eine Säge oder einen Hammer benutzt.
Das...
Eigentlich wäre mir das ans Konzalten zu doof, ehrlich gesagt, da Sachen zu fragen.
Der Scamtrain ist durch, Leute.
Nice, dass ihr euch so gut habt scammen lassen vom Scamtrain.
Ja, danke für die ganzen Subs. Fünf Abos gab es im Scamtrain. Massive.
Also bei uns auf Jelly weiß ich, dass die ganzen Consultants,
schrägstrich externe Experten oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag,
im Durchschnitt weiß ich nicht, ich weiß aber von ein paar,
die verdienen jenseits der 100k für teilweise nichts machen.
Man darf es natürlich nicht so direkt vergleichen, klar,
man muss davon auch Sachen abführen und machen und tun.
Manche weiß ich sogar jenseits der 150k.
Und in den Bereichen ist zumindest bei uns keiner,
also ich wüsste bei uns keiner, der nicht irgendwie Consultantenexperte sonst was ist,
der 150k kriegt. Außer man ist in der Schweiz.
Ich kann nicht mal Musik abspielen im Stream, da können wir garantiert keine Filme gucken.
Man könnte höchstens diese Amazon-Geschichte mal ausprobieren,
aber da kann man nur Amazon-Zeug gucken.
Wie redest du mit denen immer? Ganz normal, so wie mit euch jetzt auch.
Manchmal sage ich auch aus Versehen solche Sachen wie lulw.
Das rutscht mir echt manchmal raus in echt.
Letztens habe ich mir Socken angezogen und danach habe ich festgestellt,
die Socken passen überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Im Bad habe ich laut runtergeguckt und gesagt, keck weh.
Anstatt zu lachen habe ich einfach gesagt, keck weh.
Einfach so. Da sieht man schon, dass der Twitch-Chat das Gehirn nachhaltig beeinflusst.
Blue Faceit sagt, wechsle bald die Ausbildung von Systemintegrator zu Proggers.
Beziehungsweise Webentwicklung, irgendwelche Tipps zum Start.
Also was man so drauf haben sollte, warum wechselst du denn?
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich vermutet, wenn du quasi freiwillig wechselst,
hast du dir überlegt, das ist halt eher das, was du machen willst.
Oder liegt es daran, dass dein alter Betrieb kacke war und du den Betrieb wechseln musst?
Also das würde mich mal interessieren, was der Grund ist, warum du wechselst.
Kann ich dir vielleicht mehr zu sagen.
Ja Bastia, das geht bei vielen Sachen. Das klappt später auch noch.
Also wenn später Leute zu dir kommen und du hast keinen Bock das zu machen,
dann musst du sie einfach zu deinem Chef schicken. Das funktioniert später auch noch wunderbar.
muss einfach sein du hast keine ressourcen dabei hast was du bei uns was was witzig ist was man bei uns auf der arbeit dann gut sagen kann ist dass man gerade eingespannt ist bei einem leuchtturmprojekt oder sowas leuchtturmprojekt sind so geile ausdrücke bei uns das kriegt alles kriegt irgendwie den stempel was wichtig es kriegt den stempel leuchtturmprojekt drauf wenn du sagst ja du bist gerade stark eingespannt und das ist auch noch ein leuchtturmprojekt dann zu deinem chef schickst dann
ist vorbei dann machen sie das nicht
was hältst du für ein angemessetes einstiegsgehalt für software oder bin ich der falsche sowas zu fragen
kommt halt drauf an wo ne
also erstmal welches land und dann welches bundesland und dann halt ob es vielleicht
in der größeren stadt ist oder nicht
und dann kommt drauf an in was für einem bereich ja
bist du einer der letzten koboldudes
oder bist du einer von 30 milliarden java scriptleuten
oder java leuten oder so
wie oft habe ich in die playlist jetzt schon neu gestartet
ich rede vom jahresgehalt jaja klar
und für externe konsultants ist das brutto also 150k
ist trotzdem nicht ohne
ja ist echt so man muss sich das mal vorstellen toxi
ich bin 36 jahre
also auch schon bisschen älter ich hab graue haare teilweise
und ich stehe im bad und sagt weg
übrigens eine sache die wir jetzt
so ein bisschen etabliert haben im chat auf der arbeit ist
so als gek
da ein oder andere wird sich ja noch an anzeige ist raus erinnern
wir haben jetzt so ein bisschen etabliert das immer wenn irgendwas schief läuft
schreibt jemand abmahnung ist raus
abmahnung unterwegs
euer task force haben wir auch nekorok task force
immer wenn was ganz furchtbar wichtig ist wo keiner weiß was er machen soll
aber jetzt ist wichtig ist dass man so tut dass man was macht dann wenn das
force gebildet
wie viele stunden die woche arbeitet so ehe so um die 30
ab lymphasis ok ist intern man hat mir die stelle vorgeschlagen damit nicht
übernommen werden
unseren einzigen webmaster supporten kann
das kann sein da musste doch aber nicht wechselt man du kannst es auch als
system integrator machen machen
Der Unterschied ist eben, du kannst auch als Systemintegrator programmieren, da geht später eh kein Hahn mehr danach, was du für ne Ausbildung gemacht hast oder nicht.
Naja gut, ähm, das war nochmal die Ursprungsfrage, genau, ähm, äh, Tipps was man so kennen soll,
Naja, wenn du den Webmaster supporten sollst, dann gibt's ja eigentlich nur eine sinnvolle Sache, wenn du Entwickler bist und es um Websachen geht,
Du musst dir JavaScript, CSS oder HTML angucken, da führt nur wirklich kein Weg dran vorbei, wenn's auch noch in Richtung Frontend geht.
Beste Musik für den Hintergrund
Okay, fett Yoshi, exzellent, exquisite Musik, fett ja, wie lang geht die Playlist? 1,5 Stunden, exzellent.
Der Umwund schreibt, mein Vorgesetzter ist noch geiler, er fragt mich auch, wie konfiguriert man die Firewall und wenn man dann sagt, wenn man's ihm dann sagt, dann sagt er so, ach so hätte ich's auch gemacht.
Ja, so Leute in der Richtung gibt's bei uns auch.
Toxie, ja sehe ich auch so. Es ist aber eh so, ne? Es gibt, das fällt aber erst auf, wenn man ein bisschen älter ist.
Irgendwann bleibt das stehen im Kopf, wie alt man denkt, dass man ist. Man weiß, wie alt man ist, ja, aber irgendwann bleibt das stehen.
Also ich bin irgendwie so 25, 26, da ist das bei mir stehen geblieben. Wenn ich so im Kopf dran denke, ohne jetzt konkret an eine Zahl zu denken, denke ich so, ja, 25, 26, das ist halt schon 10 Jahre her.
Kennst du die Story von CackVersusLullWee? Klar, das haben wir schon zusammen geguckt.
Zwiebelschick schreibt, bei uns fangen die jetzt mit agilen Squats, also Agile natürlich, Agile Squats und keiner hat mehr Zeit für die eigentlich wichtigen Sachen, weil jeder nur noch im Squat-Meeting hängt.
Das ist übrigens der eigentliche Sinn von solchen agilen Sachen und irgendwelchen Squam-Geschichten und Sprints ist eigentlich, dass die Entwickler mehr in Ruhe gelassen werden, bzw. die Entwickler das bisschen besser selbst lenken können.
Aber das bleibt halt gerne auf der Strecke, wenn man nur sagen möchte, man ist agil und cool und Squam und alles, ohne es wirklich zu machen.
Bei uns war es ja auch so und das habe ich ja auch schon mal im Chat gefragt, deswegen kannst du ja heute noch mal im Chat fragen, weil es sind ja vielleicht ein paar neue Leute dabei.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit früher, früher war es so, wir haben uns einmal am Tag in eine Runde gestellt, keiner durfte sich hinsetzen und jeder hat gesagt, was er gerade macht.
Und danach haben wir gesagt, oh, das war jetzt Scrum, wir haben ein Scrum-Meeting gemacht.
Wenn man sich mal durchliest, was Scrum bedeutet, hat es nichts damit zu tun. Die eigentliche, einzige Gemeinsamkeit ist, dass empfohlen wird, dass man halt steht, dass es schneller geht, das war's.
Die ganzen anderen Sachen drumherum haben wir nicht gemacht. Man hat auch nicht versucht, irgendwie das in die richtige Richtung zu lenken.
Also da war auch keiner dabei, der sich da ein bisschen Augen drauf hat und man hat auch nicht versucht, dass die, zu etablieren, dass es nicht schlimm ist, wenn man, das ist ja auch eines der zentralen Bestandteile, wenn man sich mal so ein bisschen durchliest, wie das eigentlich gedacht ist, dass es nicht schlimm ist, wenn man sagt, man hat nichts zu sagen.
Das ist bei so einem normalen Stand-Up Scrum-Meeting eigentlich vollkommen okay, wird halt selten so praktiziert, weil es in der Regel eher in die Richtung läuft, wer nichts sagt, macht nichts.
Was eigentlich bescheuert ist, aber deswegen arten solche Meetings immer in großen Laberveranstaltungen aus, weil jeder sich gezwungen fühlt, da sich zu bewerben, was er Geiles macht.
Kennen wir wahrscheinlich auch ein paar bei euch.
Kann man mit Cobol eigentlich auch Webseiten bauen? Noch viel besser, noch viel besser. Es gibt eine Cobol JavaScript Implementation auf GitHub.
Cobol-Script, dazu kann ich bloß sagen, Rocky Linux ist auf GitHub Trending Platz 1, ja wundert mich nicht nach dem Scheiß, den sie da mit Cento als abgezogen haben.
Beste Musik für den Hintergrund, oh ne, ne, ne, ne. Ihr müsst immer dran denken Leute, wenn ihr mir Links schickt im Chat.
Ich hab ein Vorschautool, was mir anzeigt, wenn ich die Maus drüber mache, was da für ein Link dahinter steckt.
Gute Raspberry Pi Projekte für Einsteiger, irgendwas, was dir in deinem Alltag weiterhilft, also irgendwas, was du als praktisch empfindest.
Pi Hall sackt mittlerweile, weil Twitch und YouTube nicht mehr funktionieren richtig. Und es die hauptsächlichen Seiten sind, wo man es braucht.
Kennst du das KVM-Pi? Ja, das hab ich mal gesehen, das ist der Typ, der mit einer Capture-Card und USB-KVM gebaut hat, glaub ich. Auch Remote.
Zero Gap sagt, alles neumodischer Blödsinn, damit noch weniger sinnvolle Arbeit rumkommt. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, richtig gemacht finde ich es nicht sinnlos.
Wohlgemerkt richtig gemacht. Also ich hatte bisher nur die Ehre, bei einem agilen Projekt mal mitzuarbeiten, was wirklich agil war.
Und auch einen erfahrenen Scrum Master dabei. Das war schon nicht schlecht. Da wurde es zum Beispiel auch etabliert, dass es okay ist, wenn man sagt, man hat noch nichts Neues und einfach am nächsten weitergibt und sowas.
Das war nicht schlecht. Ich muss sagen, das hat schon Spaß gemacht. Du konntest dir auch raussuchen, was du machen willst und was du für wichtig erachtest, hast du dir dann eingeplatzt.
Das war schon cool. Ich finde nicht, dass das unsinnig ist. So wie es oftmals praktiziert wird, um zu sagen, man ist agil, ohne dass man das richtig macht, das ist sinnlos.
Das kenne ich, Serious Max. Da wollte ich mich sogar mal anmelden aus Just For Fun.
Für euch wurde Scrum of Scrums letzte Woche abgeschafft. Top.
Hallo, wie alt bist du, wenn man fragen darf? Was schätzt du denn? Ich sag's dir dann, was schätzt du denn?
Force Champ? Was schätzt du? Zwiebelschick, ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen. Da sind Stonks Entscheidungen im Hintergrund gefallen, das wird nicht mehr überdacht.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit auch ein Problem, wir haben 4000 Kisten CentOS. Was hältst du vom Phoenix Framework? Hab ich noch nie verwendet.
Du hörst dich an, als wärst du ein 20-jähriger. Nee, bin ich nicht. Wenn du es wissen willst, ich bin 36. Ich weiß, wirkt erstmal nicht so, aber ich bin schon ein bisschen älter.
Richtig, Boomer. Nee, mit 36 ist man zwischen Zoomer und Boomer. Um was geht's in diesem Stream? Na ja, eigentlich wollten wir uns Linux Mint angucken, aber irgendwie bin ich jetzt seit 45 Minuten schon ins Schwätzen gekommen und wir haben nicht weiter geguckt.
Glaubst du nicht 36? Tja. Ist egal, ob du es glaubst oder nicht, es ist so. Du musst es nicht glauben.
Max36 sagt gerne Kekwe im ReLive. Ja.
Facecam. Aber ich glaube, auf der Facecam erkennst du es auch nicht so richtig gut. Guckt euch den Friseur an. Den Friseur schätzt auch keiner auf 36. Gut. Jetzt kann man bei mir nicht vergleichen, ich sehe deutlich mehr 36 aus, als der Friseur 36 aussieht. Aber was ich damit sagen will, ist, dass man rein optisch da auch nicht viel drauf geben kann.
Ich habe letztens Video-Ident für Aldi Talk gemacht mit meinem Ausweis und es hat funktioniert.
Als ich 26 war, das stimmt, als ich 26 war, habe ich angefangen auf YouTube Videos zu machen. Überlegt euch mal, solange ist das schon her. Mein erstes Video ist von... Alter, ist das lange her?
Krass, oder?
Blackcombs, Blackcombs, Blackcombs, Blackcombs. Guck mal, das ist ein RC-Video mit dem Friseur, Alter. Wir waren 26. Der Friseur sah halt damals auch nicht aus. Der Friseur sah damals auch so ungefähr wie 19.
Wie heißt dein Beruf? Mach mal Ausrufe, Zeichen, Beruf. Das kommt öfters.
Okay, so Leute. Jetzt wird es aber langsam Zeit. Schön, dass so viele dabei gewesen sind. Übrigens, Leute, noch eine Frage. Ich wollte morgen ein neues Video aufnehmen. Jetzt habe ich leider meine Themenliste nicht.
Und ich habe mir heute Morgen noch überlegt, was soll ich machen. Genau, also es gibt zwei Sachen zur Auswahl, die ich mir überlegt habe, die jetzt zeitlich ganz gut kommen werden. Einmal ein Video Technik Trends 2021.
Wann streamst du wieder? Ich habe keinen festen Zeitplan. Aber du kannst mir followen, dann siehst du das. Also, ich habe einmal gedacht, ich könnte Technik Trends 2021 Videos machen, was ich mir vorstelle, was 2021 so einschlagen wird.
Oder, und ich würde sagen, das ist eine Video Idee, da bin ich ein bisschen inspiriert worden von einem englischen Channel. Ich wollte ein Video machen, Programmierer reagiert auf Programmier-Memes.
Und ich wollte anfangen mit meinem absoluten Lieblings-Programmier-Team. Das kennt ihr ja. Ich könnte mich da jedes Mal wegpissen, weil ich habe das schon so oft gezeigt. Aber das war ein absolut Lieblings-Programmier-Joke-Gag-Meme überhaupt.
Ich finde das so geil. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum. Ich glaube, aber ich finde den nur geil in Kombination mit diesen Dinosauriern. Ich finde das halt lustig. Vor allem, weil er so übelst lacht danach noch und die Audience guckt sich das an.
Verstehe ich nicht. Ja, dann machen wir schonmal einen Teil von dem Video, was ich morgen machen werde. Also Florian, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie weit du dich da mit Programmiersprachen auskennst.
Zur Erklärung, Leute. Also, damit ist nicht die Schlange gemeint, die man, glaube ich, anders schreibt. Damit ist nicht die Schlange gemeint. Das ist eine Programmiersprache.
Der Witz ist halt, dass die Programmiersprache ähnlich heißt wie die Schlange. Also sprich, warum leben Pysons auf dem Land? Ja, weil es über Sea-Level ist. Also es ist höher als Meeresspiegel und Sea-Level in dem Fall, weil C eine Programmiersprache ist, die ziemlich Low-Level ist.
Das ist der Witz dabei. Wobei man halt sagen muss, dass wenn man es erklärt, dass es nicht witzig ist. Also umso mehr man den Kram erklären muss, ist es halt dumm.
Aber für den Chat, für den Chat mache ich sowas ja. Also Leute, ich gehe jetzt pennen. Macht's gut. Ich bin müde. Wir sehen uns morgen früh. Ist Samstag heute?
Ja, Samstag. Oh, wisst ihr was ich morgen machen muss? Da habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Ich muss morgen noch Steuererklärungen fertig machen.
Fuck, Alter. Da habe ich echt keinen Bock drauf. Alles klar.
Also Leute, macht's gut. Bis denn.